I have one.
I have to boil it a Stevens.
We're live on the air.
We are,
yes,
and as you know,
Brody Stevens,
the Joe Rogan podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
Did you know that?
Produce Stevens?
I'm holding one right now.
That's not a flashlight.
That's a rubber butthole.
It has nothing to do with the flashlight is not.
That is an inferior product.
That's like a paper mache Shay Porsche,
my friend.
Okay.
It is not the same.
The same quality,
the same craftsmanship that goes into a fleshlight.
I'm telling you,
it's God damn work of art.
If they left you alone on the island with all the information in the world and
all the tools in a million years,
you'd never be able to build a fleshlight.
Right now we need a bunch of highly scientific minds,
creative minds behind this to build something like this.
Something that makes masturbation better.
It's really better than a lot of vaginas.
I'm going to be honest with you,
it's not better than having sex with a girl,
of course.
Cause there's a lot more than just the actual quality of the feeling of a girl's
vagina.
But let's be honest,
girls very in the way their vaginas feel.
Yeah.
And some of them aren't so good,
right Brody?
Unfortunately.
Yeah.
I'm sure you have.
We'll look.
We all know,
I mean,
you know,
we all know that there's somewhere out there for sure.
Unless you're some crazy freaking nature.
This guys who's got this guy has got a bigger dick than you did.
You get there.
It happens.
It has to happen.
And for the girls,
that guy with the bigger jack,
that probably feels better.
I would imagine.
It feels better.
Yeah.
I think up to a certain point,
up to a certain point,
then it starts to hurt.
But I bet it's still freaks them out that it's so big.
I bet it's exciting.
You know?
So if the guy's like not too rough with them,
I bet it does feel even better.
I bet they get used to it.
You know?
It's just natural to in the same way with tight vaginas and some girl's vagina.
It's just unfortunately are built that tight to build a slide out of baby.
Nice and easy.
We'll shrimp just like,
couldn't connect guy use a vibrator on a woman or is that or a dildo or is that
like demeaning?
Is that like I don't feel that you should ever bring tools into the equation
trying to Hitachi first though always go in strong.
No,
the problem is man,
you introduced that Shit and you've,
you basically set a bar that you can't,
you can't hit that bar on your own.
You bring in machinery and shit show you guys are high rpms batteries and you
fucking know what kind of an unnatural thing is that you're hitting her pussy
with a lawn mower,
man.
I mean what are you doing?
You're trying to vibrate her into stimulation like supernaturally in a way that
would never happen in nature.
So now you're going to get this crazy freak bitch addicted to stick and
vibrating machines into her body to make herself come.
I mean,
she's going to be trying to distract yourself from the stress of everyday life
so hard that she's just sticking things machines inside of her body just to try
and make her come.
That's what she's doing.
I don't support that.
Brody.
I support being healthy.
If a girl can't get off when you eat her pussy,
she's broken and you don't want her around.
Okay.
Orals.
You can fuck.
Yeah,
that's fantastic.
If you don't talk,
if you don't eat pussy,
there's something wrong with you.
Why would you not want to do that?
It feels great.
It feels great for the girl.
Tastes good.
[inaudible]
olives.
It's excited.
Is positive energy.
I love it.
Yeah,
it's exciting.
It's if you love a girl and you're,
and you're having sex with her,
it's exciting to eat her pussy.
Good.
I've done that a lot,
Brody,
but it's like my,
uh,
the other thing,
so I got to take like a,
I don't believe in machines.
Protein.
Okay.
Middle almost shoes.
But maybe,
what about a pill like a to help me a pill.
Viagra get full.
I need to start exercising.
I think you stopped.
Yeah,
and I think it's affected my blood flow.
That probably does,
right?
Yeah.
I'm seeing it firsthand.
The lack of exercise.
I'm full.
I'll be 42 in May and started to slow down.
Yeah.
Does that,
that's normal.
Right?
So what can I do to combat that heavy lifting,
like high intensity,
a set of like kettle bells and stuff.
Steve Maxwell showed me a bunch of different stuff that you do to sort of a slow
the aging process.
So very,
very intense.
A lot of it is a sequences of exercises.
Like you're doing a whole bunch of stuff,
whole bunch of different like complex movements in a row.
And when you do them,
like with maximum effort like that and you really blow yourself out,
apparently it just jolts your bodies and new grid system and forces your body to
start producing all kinds of higher levels of sex hormones,
testosterone,
testosterone and human growth hormone.
Your body,
when you put your body into,
if you put your body into a sedentary position,
you put your body into like some sort of an office job.
You know,
you're just sitting in the cubicle and there's not much physical activity going
on.
Your body's like,
why are we working so hard to have all these uh,
chemicals running through our body that we don't use all day?
So let's,
let's leave the day.
Let's,
let's leave the body like just like,
you know,
able to execute sentences and you know,
be able to figure things out at work.
But you don't need any physical strength at all.
He needed nothing.
He don't need to run away from Jaguars.
You don't need to fight your enemies.
You don't need any of that.
So let's just shut all that shit down.
And when your body says,
well,
if we don't need to make that and we shut all that shit down,
let's,
let's not going to be available for you in the weekends.
It's not like on the weekends when you want to do crazy shit.
All of a sudden your body springs to life,
your body responds to what,
what kind of stimulus you,
you put it under.
And if you live,
leave your body,
you know,
in a,
in a cubicle all day and you eat shitty food and you don't ever get to exercise
if you're unfortunately too busy or you just can't get motivated,
your body's defined.
I mean there's no way around it.
It's going to be a certain way.
The only way you can change that,
you gotta force yourself to do some serious fucking exercise.
Not like just go to the gym and get on the elliptical and ride that thing.
No,
you gotta do like heavy duty sets of kettlebells.
We going to do like power power sets.
Were you doing like swings,
cleans,
presses,
squats and then you do that in a set of like 20 you know when you're just blow
in your fucking system out.
When you do that kind of extra says if you force yourself to do that,
your body will respond.
I think we only use this at small potential of what our bodies are capable,
most of us do.
It's why people that like work in farms are so fucking strong.
Their bodies like developed that way.
Like they had to be.
If you ever,
you ever fuck around when a farmer no.
Also wrestle with a dude who's a farmer.
No Way.
Yeah,
you don't.
You don't want to wrestle with farmers,
man.
They're doing stuff.
The farms.
Fuck yeah,
they're throwing bales of Hay.
All debt.
Yeah.
They get ahold of you.
You feel like a little bitch.
That's a fact.
And that's it's a girl farmer.
Yeah.
That girl farmer,
you got to fuck the shit out of it,
Brian.
You can't just,
you know,
you can't just pull out machines,
but I was working out.
Can you get it back if you stop it?
Yeah,
you can get it back.
Yeah.
You have to take a lot of vitamins and minerals and you have to make sure that
you get a lot of rest.
There's a lot of things you have to do as you get older to ensure that your
body's in good shape.
It's not,
it's not as easy.
You know,
when I was 20 years old,
I didn't have to do shit.
I didn't even take vitamins when I was fighting in tournaments.
I wasn't even taking vitamins and I was just eating whatever the fuck I felt
like eating and just competing.
Right.
But then as you become 40 years old,
like man,
if you don't,
there's a significant impact for me.
I feel it significantly diet versus how my body performs in a rest versus how my
body performs.
Like everything works great as long as I get sleep and I eat well.
But if you throw either one of those out of the equation,
like you feel it,
like instantly it feel,
you know,
your,
your body is not,
it's not the same body.
I get my sleep,
knock on wood,
I make sure I get my sleep,
but it's not always possible if you're super busy,
right?
You got Force it man.
You fuck with super busy with life is what,
you know,
what's important is life.
[inaudible] these other things,
these super busy things that you throw into your life to fuck up your sleeping
and all this other that might not be right for you.
You know,
we,
we needed to pay bills,
you know,
and we,
we needed to,
to keep ourselves moving.
Where are you going Brian?
We're about to fucking end this.
Oh,
what's wrong in your mind is messed up.
What are you doing?
Did you see where the Purple Stripe is?
Yeah,
we got to talk into,
I feel like a
thank you Brian.
Sounds exactly the same.
Okay.
I'll move closer to the table.
I think it sounds the same.
It sounds exactly the same.
That was chaos.
Anyway.
Where were we fleshlight go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on a link and her in the crow name.
Rogan.
Save yourself 15% Sha Zam ba boom.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com on it is a supplement company
that,
uh,
we make,
Alpha brain,
which is a cognitive enhancing supplement.
With that is,
is a nootropic if anybody's interested in nootropics.
I say the same shit every week,
but I have to repeat it on the chance that maybe someday someone's going to find
this podcast and they'll never heard any of this shit before.
Just make it yourself.
Yeah,
he's gone.
Like,
shut up.
Brian,
Brian.
There's a lot of people that haven't heard this commercial actually have to say
it.
Yeah.
You want to make jokes commercial.
You want to mock my little my words.
So brazenly listen what I'm trying to say ladies and gentlemen,
is this things that you can do that help your mental function,
help your,
your,
your brain formed sentences better for me.
That's what it does.
I notice a difference if I'm taking it from not taking it and how smooth words
come to me.
I mean it sounds silly,
but that's what I feel,
you know,
and um,
it's,
there's a bunch of different nootropics.
Fuck,
just buying ours.
If you're interested in this stuff,
I always say go on Google and check it out.
Just Google nootropics and o.
O.
T r.
O,
p.
I.
C as in what,
what nootropics are,
is a bunch of different nutrients that have been proven to have a,
an effect,
a measurable effect on how your brain produces a like neurotransmitters and
chemicals and how they interact with each other.
It's like,
it speeds up your,
your function a bit.
It's not like crazy.
It's not limitless.
It's not like that Bradley Cooper movie where you know,
dumb person becomes a genius.
But for me it makes me feel clear and it gives me a lot.
It's great for me.
Like I love taking it when I land,
if I have jet lag,
it's like one of the best things for jet lag for me.
A pop two of those and it evens me out.
Is there anything like five h t t p
no,
that's another supplement.
That's a serotonin boosting supplement.
And that's a lot of people,
um,
that are taking the antidepressants are supposed to not take those,
you know,
there's doctors that think that you can get a too much serotonin and that with a
essentially would five HTP.
If you're not on anything and you take five HTP,
then it's fine.
But if you're on,
you know,
some sort of,
uh,
you know,
any sort of antidepressant that that boosts your Serotonin,
um,
then you,
you can actually have too much of it cause the five HTP is providing it and then
your,
your medicine is providing it to them.
But what about just like,
yeah,
what's the other than this?
Well,
it breathes,
it's five HTP,
boost serotonin and um,
there's also an El Tryptofan which actually becomes five HTP in the body we have
that are combined together on something called new mood.
And what new moon is,
is just,
it's just a,
a little bit better of a five HTP on its own is great.
If you're interested in,
you know,
you can Google that and check that out or try that yourself.
Does that,
is that I like to clear minded thing also
five.
Yeah,
I'm sure you know,
when you have more,
more happiness for sure you're going to be more clear minded.
You know,
you feel better.
I think whenever you feel better,
you can make better decisions.
I mean that,
that adds to clarity.
You know,
I just,
I'm a big believer environments,
man.
I'm a big believer in healthy diet first.
Most important because you can take all the vitamins you want.
If you're eating shitty,
crappy,
sugary fatty foods,
you know,
you're still gonna feel terrible.
It's just,
it's,
those are there.
They're really toxic for your body.
There's a lot of shit that we eat that even though it's Yummy,
it's fuck,
it's so toxic for your body.
You know,
like sugar,
sugar is fucking terrible for you.
Like drinking sodas,
tricking soda.
Like it might be just as bad as drinking alcohol.
It's terrible for you.
Sugar is like horrible free system,
you know?
Do you,
uh,
I mean,
can I cut out that and just,
should I just Chore Water?
You can.
Well,
you know what man,
I find,
and this is gonna sound so silly because it's,
it does,
it,
it seems silly,
but like I got these two things here.
One of them is this a limelight drink that my buddy Tom Atencio who used to one
of the guys that used to be at affliction,
who's my,
who's put on the MMA shows,
very nice guys,
created his own,
um,
his own energy drinks.
So you sent me something,
it's really tastes good,
but you know what else tastes good?
Fucking water man.
Water tastes good.
If you didn't have it,
you would be so psyched to get it right.
You know this,
we just,
we sort of take it for granted because it doesn't have like unusual flavors like
Coca Cola does,
right?
Right.
Dr Pepper does like,
Ooh,
I need,
I need some unusual stimulation here,
but just nice cold,
clear water is fucking delicious.
It's one of the most delicious things ever.
But our weird monkey brains crave that fucking high fructose corn syrup.
They figure out how to get us addicted to,
and it's in everything that it's in fucking serial,
it's in Soda and candy bars is an everything.
But if you can cut out 30% of that from your life that you can cut out as much
as high fructose corn syrup.
And there's,
you know,
the best I think is the Paleolithic Diet.
And not because I'm living in the Paleolithic era,
you know,
but because I think you,
your body is designed to eat what you know and the things that were natural to
us like 50,000 years ago or so,
like they say,
it takes a long time for your genes to evolve.
So if that's like 50,000 years ago and we have the same bodies of water,
bodies are designed to eat like vegetables and meat,
that's,
that's all that was there.
There really was no pasta back then.
These are the longest commercials of all time or stolen store commercial.
I can't believe it.
I have to stop this or I have to end this because this is a good subject.
Okay,
and we'll,
we'll talk about it after the break.
Look,
go to [inaudible] dot com if you're interested in nootropics,
please Google the subject.
Um,
if you enter in the code name Rogan,
you will get 10% off.
All the different supplements is shroom,
tech,
sport,
shroom,
tech,
immune,
new mood,
which is the five HTP and l trip defense supplement that we're talking about
early on.
Of course,
Alpha brain,
which is my favorite.
All right,
go there,
do it.
Don't do it.
I don't give a fuck.
Listen,
what's important is don't get ripped off,
right?
It is these,
these supplements are real,
they're legit.
But if you feel like it's a rip off,
here's the deal.
If you order 30 pills,
you get 100% of your money back that your first order.
You can't like keep ordering and keep getting your money back.
But you know how it is.
If your first order you get your money back 100% you don't have to send them
pills back it,
we just,
we don't want you to feel ripped off.
And then secondly,
Google,
Google nootropics.
If our blend isn't for you,
there's a bunch that I liked that are out there.
Neuro one was,
is a great one by a Roman Ascii,
the football player.
Oh yeah.
He created his own blend of nootropics and that's how I got into it.
That's why I was turned onto a buy a no name from San Francisco,
from uh,
uh,
the radio,
radio guy.
Morning Guy.
Listen,
go to [inaudible] dot com o n I t enter in my last name,
which is RJN.
That's Rogan.
Rhogam.
Start the show.
Get yourself 10% off.
All right,
bitches.
Brody Stevens is here.
Finally
try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Brody is me friend.
Yes.
Now we're off fellow now.
Now it's live now.
It's really happening.
Oh,
that was fun.
That was my best commercial ever.
Cause you Brody,
I felt like I bring good energy.
You do for those things.
Positive Energy.
I do.
I am good at warm up being around funny people helping with the energy possibly.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
You're,
you're a fun a cheerleader.
When we were at the comedy store,
man,
you'd always have these like really fun late nights.
That's one time I saw you at the Improv.
One of the best sets I've ever seen in terms of like how a guide turned the
audience around.
There was a,
it was a late night show.
A you probably got on,
it was probably like one o'clock in the morning by the time you got on and
people were tired.
Man.
You could see that look,
it was like a Friday,
Friday or Saturday and you came in and you put on some fucking crazy music.
It was like village people or something like that and you've got a shirt and
started swinging it through the air and like clean everybody and they had
everybody clapping along.
I mean,
it was,
it was a long time.
You did this for,
you did it for like two minutes and then you completely changed the energy of
the room and then you went up and you fucking killed.
It was like the room was dying,
man.
People were tired.
They were just not into it.
And you came out and you just completely changed the whole thing.
You walk through the audience swinging,
swinging your shirt over your head.
It was fucking great.
It was awesome.
Drums there too.
I think one time,
like on the,
on the metal railings.
Oh yeah.
It was drumming from that,
the comedy store all the time.
You're always doing that.
Yeah,
the draw me thing,
I always just thought it was funny to,
uh,
believe I was a drummer.
That was the character.
Like actually sometimes had,
you know,
the music.
I had roadies and I came out with a flashlight and they sat me down and I
drummed to a couple of songs.
It was fun.
And then I would do myself.
We talked about this in the ice house chronicles.
But,
um,
for,
for folks who don't know,
Brody Brody's,
like he's a,
he's a good friend.
He's one of my favorite comedians and he's like one of most comedians,
favorite comedians.
You know,
there's,
there's a certain thing that happens to a,
a comic when they'd been doing comedy for a certain amount of time.
I mean,
not,
not everybody,
but someone who's good where all of a sudden they,
they can make you laugh at anything.
It doesn't have to make sense.
And that's,
you got in you,
you hit that mark somewhere when you started doing warm up,
when you started doing warm up,
you got so comfortable with going up in front of people and just,
you know,
saying things to get them interested in getting,
and fucking around with the audience and bringing them all together.
You,
you got so comfortable on stage that like,
there was like a big difference.
I can remember it.
I can remember you going up and like all of a sudden like,
you know,
you,
you had figured this formula out,
you know,
you,
you would like figured out whatever your,
you know,
your Brody cadence was and you would say shit like leather exterior and we would
be out howling laughed.
Like,
what does that mean?
A car with a lever,
leather exterior,
no one could ever steal that choke,
killed cumbers not yet.
Pickles,
stuff like that.
Exactly.
And if,
if you had been you,
that was a,
that
was a,
a great time though then that,
you know,
that comedy store,
those,
um,
those sets back then,
those late nights hats.
Mostly I liked them.
Those were,
I would go,
yeah,
like be on 1231 o'clock and you get bummed out if that's all you get though.
If they like,
keeps happening,
like,
do you get bummed out now?
Like,
which they still giving you like really late.
So I'm getting better spots.
Yeah.
I get on like last night at 1115 Amit puts me,
gives me like,
on the weekends he gives me an okay spot on.
Um,
I usually go like when it's the right over the end of the hump and I get it.
I get it.
You know,
we're going to start taking you on the road with us.
If you'd done the comedy Magic Club before,
I did it last time with you like maybe four or five months ago.
You work in Saturday.
Um,
I can be,
well you are now.
Yes.
And Joy.
That's how things are booked around here.
Rogan,
positivity,
pushing roadie.
No,
I've done that.
You had me down there.
It was just,
yeah,
that's right.
Same kind of thing.
And I went down there and you know,
I was right after you got out of your situation too.
Yeah.
It was probably just getting my feet wet again.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There was one of the first times that you went on stage,
but I had no fair,
no fair.
I knew that you would just go up and crush it.
Yeah.
You know,
comedy is a,
it seems,
uh,
I don't know.
Well,
it was a real good,
good,
real good thing for you to do right then.
Yeah.
All my comedy sets had been good.
They've been getting better.
You've been crushing it,
dude.
You have a nice couple of times I've seen.
It's like,
it's empowering,
right?
It doesn't,
it make you feel like,
you know,
you've got your shit back together when you're,
you're having these great sets.
Yeah.
I feel good.
And I,
the comedians like it,
I like it.
I'm not a,
I'm relaxed.
I know,
you know,
you get,
um,
you know,
I've matured,
I've learned from everything so,
and I'm going up,
like Tommy puts me up last in the main room.
I can go on and do 35 I did 50 minutes on Saturday.
He let me do that.
I,
you know,
it was only like 20 people and then the comedians come in,
but I was able to really stretched there.
I think the next phase for me is to,
uh,
you know,
I'm still getting nervous about some things,
but who does and I'm not going to lie to you.
Yeah.
That's good.
I helped me break through that and I'd like to do that.
And I know a broader,
you're hilarious.
Just go do the road.
It's his kid out there till I'll be in her masa.
I will be in her mouth.
So Saturday we need to,
well,
and your podcast,
are you still doing that podcast with Little Leicester?
We do not have one scheduled on the books,
but the show is still a,
it's up.
It's on.
Hey,
this right now we would like to bring it back Heather.
I mean Heather,
Heather
nervous right now.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
No.
Uh,
Esther is very funny.
She was on at the comedy store last night.
She goes up.
Yeah,
she has her stuff late nights sets too,
right?
Yeah.
I mean I tell you,
yeah,
you become a better comedian at that.
But yeah,
there's nothing like going out on the road to miss those sets.
Man.
Those late night sets are fucking,
first of all,
it's so humbling.
You know those 20 people in the audience said,
but,
but I liked it.
I thrive in those situation.
Very good.
Did they show you what's
really bullshit?
Those sets,
you can fake some shit in front of a giant room full of people,
but when you get down to,
you know,
20 people,
yeah.
There's no bullshit in 20 people,
man.
They,
if it's funny,
it's funny.
If it's not,
it's fucking painfully obvious.
So I've always found,
yeah,
I've always found that those really small shows are very valuable.
Small shows in front of small,
tiny groups of people are very valuable.
I can do those.
Yeah,
they're very,
they're important because a lot of guys,
you're,
you're only getting big crowds that already like you,
so you're not exactly sure if what you're saying is full of shit.
Yeah.
You gotta you know,
especially when it's new,
you got to go over it and Redo it.
You know?
We've all had a joke that we kept a little too long.
It was like a joke from the beginning of our career where it wasn't that good.
I've got a lot of those.
You still have them?
Yeah.
I mean,
yes.
And I feel like,
oh,
when I need to write new stuff,
I will,
I'm having fun right now.
I may have rights to.
I take my sats,
I do crowd work,
I goof around,
but I definitely can sit down.
I know it just would take me a few sessions to sit down and write new jokes.
But I haven't done that because I've been focusing on other things and I've been
able to get by and you know,
maybe it hasn't.
It's made me a strong personality,
all that.
But I need to like,
yeah,
go out on the road.
Yeah,
he saw something,
have something out.
So people,
you know,
people hear about you from this podcast to hear about you from yours and other
podcasts that you go on.
They want to like,
I would like to buy a Brody Stevens,
c d,
You know,
they feel like,
why don't,
why doesn't this guy have a CD out there?
Why aren't I on iTunes?
Because,
you know,
I,
I just,
uh,
I,
here's the deal I gave myself when I got out of a,
the UCLA thing.
I got we just to say,
I gave myself,
okay,
let's explain this to people because no one know this is something a lot of
people listen to this podcast that had no idea what the story is.
I don't know the exact details.
So you don't mind.
You tell the folks what happened to Brody Stevens.
Okay.
See you exactly the same as it was before this incident.
But there's an incident and I had heard about it like second or third hand,
I had heard,
holy shit,
there's a public
incident within the comedian community.
So what happened?
Basically,
um,
I was doing comedy and I went to Ireland to perform and went to Ireland,
perform there,
never been over there before.
Did well.
Then I went straight from Ireland to Montreal,
went to Montreal,
got sick,
physically sick,
Montreal.
I was taking Lexapro up into that point for basically to take the edge off.
I guess my regular doctor gave it to me.
He said,
how long did you taking it for?
Four years.
How much of a difference did it make?
I mean,
I think it even me out,
whatever that means.
But I still like would,
you know,
staring in the mirror at myself,
be hard on myself,
but I wouldn't like feel it.
It wouldn't physically affect me.
Whoa.
So you would
still do the same things,
but it would be dull.
You wouldn't,
you wouldn't feel the emotional impact of staring in the mirror and,
yeah.
What would you do when you're staring in the mirror?
Uh,
see if my beard's perfect.
Look at this scar on my face.
Oh,
you're not talking to yourself or no,
I would.
No,
no,
no.
I don't talk to myself.
I don't,
uh,
I don't hallucinate.
Well,
top notch violins yourself
does not hallucinating.
This is people who talk to themselves to work things out.
I don't think there's anything wrong with talking to you.
I'm sure everybody does a little bit,
but sounds weird.
But what,
who gives a fuck?
Why isn't weird to talk to yourself?
It's weird to think in your head,
but it's not weird to think out loud.
What if you want to hear the words?
What is that?
Is that crazy?
I mean,
it doesn't make any sense to me.
I think if you're a crazy person and you're talking to your staff,
we think someone else is engaging in a conversation.
But sometimes hearing things out loud and defining them by saying it in a
sentence sometimes that makes you address things that you would ordinarily
address if they were just sort of abstract concepts,
not attached to language.
Something you weren't happy with that you did I need to someone or,
yeah,
or something you're not happy with as far as like you know,
fulfilling certain aspects of your life or you know,
not being disciplined enough.
So yeah.
But when you,
when you say it out loud,
okay Joe,
you're a fat fuck,
you need to go to the gym.
If I,
if I was your friend,
I would tell you you're a fat.
Fuck me.
You know when when you have like that sort of a conversation with yourself.
Yeah.
Sometimes it does not a bad thing to say out loud.
I feel like I need to get back to the gym.
I really do
cause I,
but I gave myself six months off to six months to no exercise.
No nothing.
Well I have been,
but honestly I haven't had the motivation.
I'm stressed out a little.
I am,
I get,
I get stressed somewhat.
I'm hard on myself but,
but I would think that the work and that would help dot.
Yeah.
And I need to do that,
but I'm also,
um,
I'm on a medication maybe or what kind of medication?
I take Depakote,
what does that,
but I'm only on it for like another few months.
So you started off in the lip,
Lexapro you take that got sick and Canada stop
before that you take the Lexapro.
Yeah.
So the Lexapro you,
this is the first time you'd ever not taken it or gotten off of it?
Yeah.
I may have got off at one time a long time.
And if you get off of it though,
you're supposed to wean yourself off.
Correct.
And I didn't because I was sick.
That's the thing.
I was so physically sick up and I hadn't been that sick in years.
Lou or something.
Yes.
I didn't want to put anything in my body and I'd been wanting to get off Lexapro
just because it makes me go pee at night and you can't drink beer and,
but that's,
you know what,
that's the trade off probably for having at work.
And when you feel like something's not working,
it's working.
You know what I mean?
Huh?
What,
what?
Like if somethings you feel like you're in a good mood,
I don't need to be on this anymore.
Keep taking it.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
That too.
So,
um,
so your doctor just sorta gave it to you to take the edge off.
You weren't complaining about anything like really specific.
That's really,
no,
it was,
that seems,
that seems kind of crazy,
man.
That seems crazy that a doctor would just prescribed pill like that looking take
the edge off.
I mean,
instead of telling you to like maybe try yoga or,
you know,
well,
you know what,
that's what I need to do.
I haven't done it.
I haven't done yoga,
um,
ever.
But I was exercising.
You seen these videos?
That was one thing I did and I felt like,
um,
I could eat what I wanted to because I was exercising.
I also had a regular gig doing audience warm up for nine years basically.
So every week I was getting a paycheck,
doing audience warm up and then I have not been doing audience warm up for a
couple of years.
And it's been,
I'm not saying I'm not blaming that on,
it's been an adjustment for me and I have to start thinking like,
this is my opportunity.
You know,
people think I'm funny,
but you know,
I kind of went at it a different way through this audience warmup.
Well you sort of took a job along the way and it was a good job and yeah,
it made you better as a comic.
Yeah.
But it's time to let go the teat.
Right.
And that,
and it's taken about two years and um,
I think that I,
yeah,
I put little Ipod,
sometimes I'll put extra PR,
I put pressure on myself,
but I think the fact that I wasn't on the Lexapro and I stopped cold Turkey just
kind of made it
wars.
And you didn't feel like you are crazy.
You felt like everybody was over reacting.
Right.
Uh,
I thought my friends were,
I actually yet,
to be honest,
I thought they were overreacting.
I thought like,
um,
yeah,
I felt like they were overreacting.
Yeah,
I've listened.
I've been around people that have been high too high and have a conversation.
I've been around people that have been too drunk and are embarrassing,
but there's nothing weirder than people that are on pills,
man.
You know?
And I'm not saying that Lexapro is like everything else,
so it's not like oxycontin's or it's not like Xanax or something.
There's a,
there's a certain,
something that happens when people are taking like pills now,
pharmaceutical pills,
the,
the effects are very rarely positive.
You know,
when,
when I hear someone's taking pills,
you know,
this,
this Lexapro stuff.
I don't know if you needed it,
you know,
I don't know what the doctor saw her,
you know what you said to him?
I don't,
I don't know.
But I know that that stuff,
especially when you get off of it or if you mix it with anything else,
it's very tricky.
I mixed it with pot.
Yeah,
you stop taking Lexapro cold Turkey.
I was on Canadian antibiotics and then I had regular stresses may be from the
dis,
all these good things that were happening to me and then I was kind of
celebrating and I actually wasn't stressed out.
I was celebrating and then my friends were like freaked out and people in that
kind of like got to me.
I was in a good mood and they and and
which is the one that's supposed to make you crazy if you would take it with
alcohol?
Is it Zoloft?
Zoloft is like alcohol and cocaine.
It makes a psychotic or something like that.
Do you think though it may be that a lot of people are having more successful,
there's a more successful rate with people that are on it though that just don't
talk about it and you don't even know they're on it.
I think that seems like there's a lot of people that are on these things.
I,
most of it's good.
I think we just hear about once in a while we hear a crazy person do it.
That's one out of a fail.
You should be very careful when you make a statement like most of it's good
unless you've done some serious research and really can back it up because it's,
it's very controversial.
I think for some people it's definitely helpful.
I have a friend that had helped him a lot and he had a a real serious bout with
depression,
couldn't get his shit together,
got on antidepressants,
got himself together,
started getting in shape,
turned his life around.
It became completely positive,
got a real like good amount of success under his belt and then weaned himself
off of them and you know he's,
he's much happier guide.
He had to change the way his brain was wired.
He had to change the way he was making connections with life for him.
It was almost like a,
gave him a push start.
He gave him a fresh chance at it and a,
I forget which antidepressant he was on,
but he was on it.
I know I've had a few friends that have been on them and they benefited from it.
I know,
I know there's a benefit to it,
but I all Dow,
I also get scared.
I get scared when you know,
I know that people are putting people on these things and it's just to take the
edge off.
You're like Jesus Christ.
He knew you're,
you're changing the way someone's brain chemistry is essentially permanently.
I mean,
you know,
you're,
you're in,
you're locked into these fucking pills.
These,
they become a part of the way your mind functions now.
Like when you get off of it,
it becomes very tricky,
right?
Your whole brain is out of whack and that's where you were your,
your whole brain.
It's like there's no all of a sudden where the,
where's the fucking Lexapro?
We've been running on Lexapro for x amount of years and now it's not even here
anymore.
So your ability to deal with stress and all the different,
you know,
the d,
The d,
the different,
yeah.
Put that was coming at you.
You couldn't handle it.
It was just,
you're just whacking out,
right?
Yeah.
What was it like?
What did it feel like?
Well,
I mean I was thinking,
um,
yeah,
when that was going on it felt,
uh,
I felt fine.
I just felt,
I felt like I thought it was,
I knew I was on some kind of bender and I knew my friends are like freaking out,
but I was actually happy,
but I was a little combative.
MMM.
But I was in a good mood,
but then I went too far.
I didn't,
I didn't nail the landing.
And when I want on Twitter,
people were saying like,
this is funny.
Like his hashtags and what he's doing.
And then people got,
they got scared and then them getting scared,
Kinda like I was,
it was part performance art.
Yes.
Because I was trying to be funny and like I knew it was,
but I didn't realize everyone was looking at me.
But the bottom line is,
yeah,
I was,
I stop Lexapro cold Turkey.
I think that's what,
for me,
even though my doctor,
he thought that this was just a real manic episode.
Just w Lexapro or not
doctor sounds like a Douche bag.
Well,
there's two of them doctors.
Like what do you get?
You get to feel edgy here,
let me change the way your brain works.
And uh,
then Oh,
I think he just got manic there fella.
Right.
Well,
you know that that's what,
that's what,
uh,
why wouldn't
he think that that was Alexa blow Lexapro withdrawal issue?
I don't know.
He's
giving you pills.
It changed the way you think.
You stopped taking them and you go bump
just for a little bit.
Well this is a different guy that my general practitioner,
that was a guy who says,
you be on Lexapro,
you need to be on the restaurant.
They do that.
It's not,
it's not,
uh,
I don't want to,
but they do that.
He said,
wow,
this is like five,
six years ago.
The reason why I got on stuff because I just,
my mind was always working instead of like,
um,
you know,
learning yoga instead of like,
I was around baseball and I didn't,
I wasn't in like a supportive,
um,
artistic comedy community.
What do you mean?
You're saying your mom was always working and that's why you got on Lexapro,
like tired all this working,
what would he saying?
Yeah,
like,
um,
oh no,
I was just too hard on myself.
I've always been hard on myself and
did you okay.
But that's not like working,
you know,
you're,
you're saying,
you're saying your brain was always working.
Brain's always thinking,
so it's not the,
you're thinking about things is that you're thinking badly about yourself.
Yeah.
Low self esteem and it just repeats over and over again in your head.
Sometimes you have low self esteem and then a little bit of like the OCD,
I got to look a certain way.
Then I start feeling,
I mean buddy,
these are things that are,
I know normal.
They're normal.
I just got to learn to deal with them better.
And maybe I'm a late bloomer.
May Be,
you know,
it's taken me until,
age 42 to figure it out.
I don't know.
What do you think?
I think you're a great guy.
Um,
I,
I don't like seeing anybody in a confused state that's trying to figure
themselves out.
You know,
I just feel like
that's a very tricky situation.
It's very,
uh,
you never know what kind of advice to ever give anybody when they're trying to
figure shit out,
you know?
What do you say to them?
What can you say?
I know.
I don't know how your mind's working.
Well,
I think right now,
um,
you know,
my comedy has been great.
I feel good.
I'm relaxed on stage.
It's like these problems that I seem to be,
and they're not even,
they're not unsolvable problems.
I feel their normal problems,
but the comedy has really been good and I'm relaxed.
I'm not,
I think the Lexapro,
yes.
The problems like staring at yourself in the mirror,
like talking about that.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
Well it's all there.
I want to stop.
So next Miros hilarious.
I need a check to say Brody.
Relax.
That's the last one.
Oh,
I don't need that.
I do.
What you need is okay.
Don't need that.
I don't need that.
He needs that.
You,
if you need a check,
it's just to be your friends.
Love you will,
you don't need as a chick that tells you what to do,
but he needs to fuck some pussy up for a while.
Like in like three months of fucking pussy up and then,
yeah,
but that's why nice.
Or women you need Viagra or something.
Needs to have sex with women.
I mean that's,
yeah,
it's almost 40 my libido.
Pussy man.
Seriously,
it's been a while,
right?
Brody?
Like it's unique.
It's your time to fuck some pussy up for a while.
Brian.
Brian,
do you see,
listen to how you're phrasing this.
Fuck some pussy up doesn't even sound convinced it's time to,
I'm to
make love to a woman.
I want times a day.
I know if I went on the road I'd probably hook up with checks.
Yeah.
If you went on the road you'd would,
yeah.
Really.
What kind of you liked cute girls that are into me.
How,
what,
what age bracket?
Uh,
probably like tall blonde.
She was Jewish women,
right?
No,
I like a blonde.
I don't know.
I don't actually,
I don't like dicey tall blonde.
Jewish?
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
That's what he said before.
Once.
You know what?
They're cute and they're into me,
but I see cute girls,
but half the time they're with a,
you know,
they got a boyfriend or they're not into me.
You know?
Also being in Los Angeles is a tough place to meet girls.
When you say Joe,
uh,
yeah.
It's probably not the place where you want it.
Well,
I have a very strict,
no head shots policy.
I think it's very important.
Don't date anybody that's like,
you know,
nobody in the business.
Nobody.
Yes.
And when you do that,
you know,
you're cutting out most of the Los Angeles,
you're cutting out a huge chunk to date.
Someone who's never doesn't want to be an actor.
And it's not,
there's anything wrong with being an actress.
It's just that I find my personality collides with people that are also
performers,
you know?
And especially a lot of performers are fucking super needy and they want to talk
about their career all the time.
I,
that shit gets tired,
man.
I don't,
I don't like talking to my,
about my career to anybody.
I don't talk about it to my wife.
And I'd very rarely talk about to my comic friends.
You know,
I just do my shit and just I could concentrate on my work and that's it.
I don't,
I don't want to be around someone who's like me.
You know what?
Because the odds of them being like me and me liking them and being me being
able to like be around them all day every day and deal with their nonsense.
No,
no.
We're at civilians.
Civilians.
Yeah.
Regular people,
man.
You know,
and somebody,
somebody got annoyed when you fucking cold.
This is the stupidest fucking tweet ever.
I hate when you call,
when you comedians called regular people don't do comedy civilians.
It's a total insult to our armed forces.
It's funny,
you fucking Dork,
whoever you are out there.
You dork.
I hope it wasn't just trolling.
He wasn't trolling man.
I looked at some of his other Rah Rah Rah tweets and I wanted to kick him right
in the Dick.
But Joe has nothing wrong with loving American boy.
Just don't be a pussy about it.
This isn't a Goddamn captain America movie.
You crazy bitch is a reason why comedians call regular folks.
Civilians is because comedians are weird as fuck.
And if you wanted to pretend that the whole world is filled with Comedians,
you'd be able to say anything anywhere.
You'd be able to say the rudest rape joke at the top of your lungs and a
restaurant while you're on a hot date,
comedians wouldn't care at all.
You,
you almost have to think of the other people that like when someone is,
especially like when it comes to like a senses of humor and the uh,
you know,
willingness to get insulted by something like that.
It's almost impossible to insult the average comedian.
You know,
if you have a bunch of us and you came into a room and there was a bunch of us,
you've pretty much feel like you could say whatever you want it.
Yeah,
isn't it one of the beautiful things about being a comic,
like when you would go to the comedy store and pull into the back,
you step out of your car,
you could scream the n word at the top
of your lungs.
And we,
and we would just go,
what's up Brody?
You can say whatever you want.
You could just,
you know,
you could just hello niggers and we would just go,
[inaudible] said that somebody stopped.
I'm saying,
I'm not saying it,
I'm saying if he said that,
we would have no problem with it.
You could say the most ridiculous thing ever.
Because comedians for the most part are almost impossible to,
to insult like that.
Right.
And that's an average person would be very insulted.
The average person and you know,
really off color things,
you're taking a huge chance.
And I did that on Twitter.
I was being,
so I was on Twitter and people saw that and they go,
this guy's freaking out.
Did you see what we're Louis Ck wrote about Sarah Palin?
It was fucking hilarious.
He went off about Sarah panel at all.
He was drunk on an airplane.
It was just tweeting about her calling her contract and now he won't do the
thing.
Yeah,
it was great.
It was great.
Would you describe Twitter for the people that don't know why Twitter is pretty,
people don't know what to do.
Yes,
they do Twitter,
it's pretty common with Brody Brody's obsessed with Twitter and Ian,
that's something that you've been talking about lately.
Maybe backing down from Twitter and I've been trying to tell him that's a bad
idea.
As a performer,
as a comic,
I think act out your biggest tool.
Twitter is amazing.
I'm just obsessed by my number.
You are.
I'm a,
I'm impressed.
And yet,
um,
you know,
I find out so even you get obsessed about your followers.
I get excited when I say go up.
Do you compare yourself to other people?
Like somebody as a million favorably,
unfavorably to like a lot of famous people might dam and let me ask a question.
Barely hanging in there.
But if I saw Courtney Cox you the day and I smash her with my numbers.
That's cool.
Now does that stress you out,
Josie,
that would like gives me stress?
No.
Why not?
Because I do a lot of Jujitsu.
That's what stresses me out.
My stress comes from real men trying to strangle me.
This is silly nonsense to me.
So this his fun.
I mean like when I look at like my Twitter number,
I go like,
Ooh,
come on bitch,
I want to get a million.
But you also think about,
I don't freak out.
Are you on all those websites?
So that follow and track like,
like twit star or fade star that I didn't even know about.
Oh yeah.
[inaudible]
you'll become like a stockbroker with birds.
It's,
you'll fucking go crazy shows how many retweets and favorites you get.
Minor.
I just like when depressed will enjoy,
I enjoy a good Twitter exchange.
You know what I enjoy?
I enjoy putting up a cool link and then having a bunch of people respond to the
link and then a bunch of people will tweet me like related links that are even
more interesting sometimes.
You know,
it's like you get on this little um,
uh,
vibe about something.
Any,
any subject that you wind up posting about and you can learn a lot of shit
through Twitter and just took a few minutes.
Yeah,
I get the news and everything.
Fuck,
it's great for news man.
I found out when they killed a Kadafi that was on,
I found that out on Twitter before I heard that it was like a couple of
different news things.
It was seen on Twitter.
Jeff Ross tweeted it,
deaths when people die as he looks like when Whitney Houston died,
that was on Twitter.
I found out immediately on Twitter.
Yeah,
Twitter.
I go,
yeah,
I'm on it all the time.
I follow a lot of people.
Some people think I follow too many people,
but I know a lot of people.
I follow them.
I know a lot of people follow a lot of people.
Brody,
you're respected and you're well known.
Have you heard about these tattoos that uh,
no key is coming out with Brian?
Oh yeah.
Oh Dude.
No.
Kia is coming out with tattoos that will vibrate when your fucking phone is
ringing.
That seems like I heard about that.
Oh,
you know what,
that's,
that's the most ridiculous thing if you think about it,
because like what if you had like a tattoo back in the 80s that was like,
dude,
it's a double cassette player in your arm.
You know?
Like right now,
you'll be like,
yeah,
I got this double cassette player in my arm know who's going to care about the
fucking vibrations and 20 years or you might have to get that shit carved out of
your flesh.
Right.
But,
uh,
it's no key in these crazy bastards.
Nokia apparently is like the number one or one of the number one cell phone guys
in the world.
And even though like they're getting crushed now by apple,
like up until the iPhone came along,
they had like some of the most innovative phones they had.
Like they have like one phone.
It's like,
uh,
like at the top of the line.
Shit right now.
It's amazing.
Beautiful phone.
But she can never get into it because the operating system is like some wonky
thing that they created and it's like,
where's this going?
This operating system is going nowhere.
You know?
I mean,
you know,
when there's windows phones,
you know that windows is always going to be around when there's yeah.
Know an apple phone,
you know that apple is always going to be around,
but there's no key,
uh,
you know,
Weirdo fucking,
it's not working over here.
What is that noise?
Are you singing over there?
No.
You didn't hear that?
No,
no.
Really?
Wow.
I was talking about,
yeah.
Do you hear that?
What was that?
Oh,
no,
lots.
It's people in the other rooms.
Fucking ghost here.
We w w here at the Ice House.
Ice House is a fucking great club.
It's amazing comedy club in Pasadena.
And um,
they have,
uh,
a tele communications room that we took call it.
What is the Tele advanced security room?
Advanced security.
Yeah.
Is it called like phone spam?
Yeah,
essentially.
It's like when you go to a comedy club and they say,
you know,
fill out this,
uh,
your address and you,
you know,
we'll put you on raffles to win tickets.
Yeah.
And so it's kind of that.
But what it really is,
is just come to a comedy club,
you know,
help us out.
This place is a bad ass fucking place.
This is,
this is one of the best clubs in the country.
No doubt.
50 year anniversary,
55 zero.
Isn't that amazing?
Yeah.
And there's two rooms here.
That's one of the things that make it so bad ass.
There's a little 85 seater that we always do our a death squad chosen and
they're the most fun man.
I,
I have a lot of new shit that I've been working on in these little,
the little 85 seater.
It's like,
it's so intimate in there.
It's so perfect.
Crowds are great.
Yeah.
Why,
why we're doing our,
um,
yeah,
Brian Needed Dick last time,
but while we're doing our podcast right next door,
there's a telemarketing group.
They're calling people up.
That's what all that noise was.
You know what?
I've never followed Sam Tripoli.
He,
uh,
it was Saint Patty's day or whatever it's called and he,
he's really engages the audiences I've noticed.
Uh,
cause I watched his set and he's just like getting up wound up following him on
Saint Patty's Day with when everyone's drunk and young.
That was one of the hardest sets I've,
I've ever done.
I don't know if I could follow the same AAA.
He needs to be as close.
There's a fucking headline clothes.
I brought him with me a,
a bunch of Canadian gigs.
He fucking crushed dude.
He,
he does great.
He's a,
he's a real common.
He man,
Sam's veteran,
you know,
say I'm probably around crushes.
I love watching them too.
It's fun comedy,
you know,
he's a fun dude.
You know?
It's like,
he's like,
he's there.
He's like a party leader,
you know.
It's fun.
He's got Nadie so Thursday comedy store.
Comstack yeah,
Sam Tripoli's.
Uh,
he's a great dude.
I love that guy.
I love going on the road with them too.
Is it hard to follow a guy like that?
Like good to follow dot that because the crowd is already laughing.
Yeah,
it's easy.
Yeah.
Just as if your materials good.
But there's a lot of guys,
they don't like that pressure.
You know,
we've talked about this a few times on this podcast.
A lot of guys go on the road and they take someone on the road that's,
you know,
not gonna show them up.
You know,
it's kind of like,
yeah,
it's important to them.
They want to go on the road with someone who's just okay enough to get the job
done and then,
then you go up and you look or your hero and you knock it out of the park.
I'll be with I,
Joey d is an Ohio cause that what you're trying to call yourself,
is that what you are now Brian?
You know,
people want to hear you.
You're fine.
You got some good stuff here.
Here's,
I'm going to be give you some public criticism.
You just need to decide if you're going to do it.
Yeah.
Comedy is not something you could do like one day,
every three weeks and think about it for five minutes before you do it and do
the same jokes again.
Right.
If you want to do it,
I only do it a lot.
I only do it about once,
twice a week now.
And I tried new jokes on stage because I feel a lot of these crowds,
I've already seen me already.
So a lot of my shit's like half open mic,
half PR to practicing old bits.
Dude.
You know it's like a workout you have with this podcast is a legitimate
opportunity to become a professional comedian.
All you have to do is choose to write jokes and start performing on a regular
basis and you could do the road all the time and you don't ever have to work for
me or anybody else or I don't think I or would ever want to work the run the
road.
I don't think I'd ever want to do that fucking traveling.
I'd rather just stay at home and have sex.
It's now go and look at TVs and stuff.
Wow.
You won't see.
You either have to have the road and you are not like traveling does take a lot
out of you.
You love the road,
you're on the road all the time.
I'm amazed you could even survive cause I mean I would want to be home with kids
and kissing kids and you know,
stuff on that every week.
What are you talking about?
I'm never on the road for more than a few days at a time ever.
Yeah.
And I'm all,
I'm on the road a lot of weekends,
but that's how I make my living,
you know?
And I think that if you're a professional stand up comedian,
in order to be on top of your game,
you have to do it all the time.
I've tried it both ways.
I've tried doing like one show a week for like a couple of weeks.
It's not good.
The best way to one show a week is like just enough to keep you tuned up.
And if I do that,
then I make myself listen to recordings.
Stand up.
Comedy is a vibe you have to be,
you have to be able to pull people in to that,
that feeling that you get when you're just on top of it.
When you really got your timing down,
you're,
you're in the moment perfectly.
And that's not an easy vibe to recreate if you're out of shape,
if you're at a comedy shave.
But so once you're in comedy,
like as a comic,
as a professional,
I think that's,
it's very critical that you got to perform a lot.
I try to get onstage,
right.
Get onstage like three,
four nights a week here.
That's hard to do an ally.
It is hard to do in La.
And then I'll,
you know,
mix a podcast.
I'll pick up another show like,
well I get three.
Yeah.
Like sometimes maybe I'll get him,
I'll get on more than that.
The road is the best because if you're doing,
like I'm doing Louisville next weekend,
this weekend we're at the Comey magical up tickets mall almost.
Hold on.
Yes.
Comedy and Magic Club.
Friday and Saturday.
Um,
Duncan trussell's doing both nights.
And um,
I find that when you do like a whole weekend,
he'd do four shows in a row.
Two on Friday,
two on Saturday.
Yeah.
Sometimes one on Thursday or Sunday.
Man,
by the time that wrong,
that's on each show.
Saturday comes around,
you just knew bits just become crushers.
Yeah.
That's the bad.
If you got a new bid on Thursday and you jump on stage with it and by Saturday
night,
how good does it feel when it becomes like a new weapon,
you know,
get that makes me so excited.
It makes me hard to sleep.
I go back to the hotel,
I can't fucking sleep.
You're excited.
I want to write more.
You know,
it's like what you,
what you create when you create a great bit,
when you create something and all of a sudden people love it and they get
excited by it and you see it kill in front of thousands of people.
You created this,
this,
this burst of energy.
You created this moment,
this positive thing,
this,
this laughter inducing thing.
This,
you pieced it together with words and expression and idea and you've created
something that has the ability to extract good feelings out of people.
Laughter,
hilarity.
And that's so addictive.
Once you do it,
and once you get that feeling and you realize that it's,
it's in you and you,
there's more of it in there.
You just got to pull it out by writing.
Just force yourself to sit down and write and constantly work at it and you,
you just put all your focus in it and boom,
you're rewarded at boom,
you're rewarded.
It's one of the most beautiful things I think in,
in all of all of life.
Being human,
it's being able to create something and then bring that shit on stage like right
away and have people laugh at it.
It's one of the fucking greatest gifts ever.
So how do I get booked for those rooms?
How does that send out?
But I'll tell you what,
when you're saying this,
I did headline,
I went down to La Jolla.
I have gone down there with Sam Aaa and these other voice doesn't count.
I know it doesn't,
it doesn't count,
but it was for me.
It's a club for me.
But it doesn't count because anybody can headline that thing.
They'll,
they'll have crazy headliners down there.
They have,
they've done some particular shows down there,
right,
where people are headline and you're like,
what?
They shouldn't be.
Yes.
Well maybe I wasn't one of those guys.
None.
Well,
but it helped me.
I mean,
I did four shows down there and the kid who went on before me was pretty good.
When or how long ago was this?
Uh,
like,
uh,
six weeks ago and ask us to tweet it.
Rooted,
tweeted the shit out of that.
People from this podcast,
we'd love to go see you alive.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I think they were a,
yes.
Yeah,
dude,
this is how it works.
Anytime you ever have anything you do,
you tell us and we'll tweet it.
And then if you,
you know,
if you ever want to come on the podcast and talk about something and you're
going to do you just come on podcast,
tell us.
But if you,
if you're doing a gig somewhere,
definitely let us know so that we could tweet it.
You know,
I like doing podcasts.
I love doing the red band podcast.
I love doing the ice house chronicles.
Those are all,
I did Ari's podcasts.
I've done stuff with Duncan.
I'm enjoying my comedy.
I'm working on this HBO project.
It's like I want,
I got a lot of things going on,
but it's like I just try to be me.
Right?
It seems to be working right,
but I want to do,
I want to do the road.
I feel like I'll,
I'm gonna have to wait for something else to happen.
What you should do at the road,
you should do the road with a couple other guys.
You should get like a Tripoli or you know,
someone else that,
that can draw off the internet.
People that everybody knows from the Internet,
you know,
like if say like him and Tripoli,
like you and Tripoli and Brian say of you and Tripoli and Brian decided to do a
couple of dates and Tempe,
Arizona.
Tell me,
yeah,
tell me.
You guys wouldn't kill it.
We would write,
you can't,
I bet you guys could get 300 400 people in a night.
I really believe that.
I agree.
Yeah.
If you do like a Wednesday night or Thursday night and used,
do a reasonable ticket price price,
you know,
and that's it.
That's a great show.
Trips,
Tripoli would headline it said when you become,
and you become a better comedian,
doing those shows too,
is you become a better comedian when you do a lot of different audiences.
You have to be able to deal with the conservative audiences.
You know,
that you would get,
may be in certain parts of Texas and the liberal audiences that you would get in
certain parts of California,
San Francisco,
northern California,
and northern California is very different than southern cal.
Oh yeah.
Northern California is maybe twice as smart as southern California.
They're hard audience there.
They're great audiences.
In my favorite I,
I did,
uh,
one of my cds,
they're shiny happy Jihad just because I just love it.
I think San Francisco is,
if you,
if they're laughing,
it's cause it's fucking funny.
There's,
you know,
they're,
they're like,
they're the smartest.
I think the most read it maybe New York City is pretty,
pretty close up to their,
you know,
they're,
they're probably right.
Right.
Neck and neck with each other.
Yeah.
So you can't pull over any,
no,
no dumb shit.
It's very DIY.
You can do dumb shit in San Francisco,
in New York either.
I mean there's parts in New York and his burrows and suburbs and you know,
you get road gigs,
you might be able to get away with some stupid shit.
But in Manhattan She's as Christ,
you better have good comedy,
you know,
that's,
that's a real city.
These are real people.
They're not stupid.
You're not going to get them with tricks.
And a lot of these people that go to these Manhattan comedy clubs,
I mean these are goddamn comedy because kind of sores,
you know,
they're fans of Lenny James.
Yeah.
They might have Lenny Bruce vinyls at home,
you know,
I can San Francisco,
there's a lot of like real comedy fans in San Francisco.
Like I've talked to people about this show and you know,
Super Nice people and they,
oh,
thank you very much.
We come every week and then whenever there's a comic and talents,
our favorite thing to do,
we've seen pat nozzle always seen Du,
Du,
we to a lot of,
we have a lot of weed up there,
a lot of weight.
A lot of couples now.
He didn't mean couples like we,
you know,
we'd,
um,
but um,
there's a lot of,
uh,
you know,
people who love it.
Like there's people that are like jazz kind of sewers,
you know,
and they want to just go out and see like live jazz.
They know who the artists are and they go see it in a regular basis.
I find that the,
the two places where that happens,
the most that I experienced is a San Francisco in New York,
San Francisco,
New York.
It seems to be like there's a lot of people that are just really,
really into comedy.
I like the history of comedy.
I've had like the most cool like history of comedy conversations with people.
There's always people that are like fans of one or two,
one a few guys like Hicks or Kinison like that comes up a lot of my shows
because they know that I was a big fan of those guys,
you know?
But as far as like a,
you know,
like cities where your company has to be top notch,
you gotta think like New York and San Francisco,
the top two.
Right.
I love performing in New York.
I did the lower east side.
That was,
I mean that wasn't the clubs.
I did stand up New York.
I was a barker at the comedy cellar.
I barely got on at Boston comedy club maybe once.
Boston comedy was great.
Yeah.
What is that like 80 seats?
How many seats was that?
Yeah,
it was something like that.
Small players.
Great.
I used to love doing that place,
man,
but I wasn't,
I wasn't really,
I wasn't really past there,
so I mean it was,
I,
I would be intimidated.
I was so intimidated that I worked at the comedy cellar.
I just never asked to get past.
I used to do sets at Boston and it would be me,
Jim Brewer.
Dave Attell.
Yeah,
Dave Chappelle.
I mean,
it would just crazy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And then there's some other guys like really funny guys from New York,
like Greer Barnes and all these other guys,
but just kill or after killer.
And we,
you have the sense like when you were watching Nick de would go up,
you had this sense like,
wow,
you know,
I'm around like I'm around some like really heavy talent.
You know,
you had the sense with like,
wow,
these guys are,
you know,
these guys are going to be fucking huge.
Which it was at.
Um,
I mean,
is that happen like everywhere or because you were younger,
you were already,
it'd be,
I mean,
is that specific to New York or is that specific to like
New York always has a lot of talent for sure.
Right?
There's waves though.
I was a,
I came on a very fortuitous wave,
you know,
where I got to see a lot of like super talented guys,
I mean,
my wave,
when I first moved to New York,
I saw Dave Chappelle performing.
He was like really young man.
Dave was way younger than me.
I'm 44 and I was 21 at the time.
20 No,
22,
maybe 23 at the time,
the most 23 and uh,
Dave was way younger than me.
He was like 17 or 18 or something like that.
I don't know how old he was.
Yeah.
But I got to see him,
uh,
perform at catch a rising star and I was like,
wow,
how bad ass is this kid?
He was like super chill and he had the,
I don't remember,
I was thinking like what a great stage presence.
He has like a really like enjoy watching him talk and he's like really
compelling and yet he's so young,
which is really rare.
You know,
when someone's young,
usually they try too hard,
they rushed,
they're too anxious to have you pay attention.
There's,
it's distracting that they're not on the right vibe but at like as a young
teenager,
he just had the right vibe on stage.
He knew how to draw you in.
It was a,
he was a compelling speaker,
like as a young man.
And then he was really funny too.
On top of that,
he had some great bits,
great timing and Shit.
I got to see like a tell,
develop his style,
you know,
a tell like slowly became that guy.
He might go.
A lot of that was,
you know,
it was like you could watch it like come together over the years and then it
became like the most copied style of delivery ever.
Maybe for the media of New York.
Definitely.
Yeah.
What is it basically,
you know,
comedy don't stop.
You know,
you just keep going.
You're always going to get better.
Hopefully in some people.
Some people don't get better.
It's like anything in life,
there's no guarantees,
man.
That's what's scary about it,
you know?
I wish I could tell you.
Yeah,
keep going and you'll get better.
It's no,
I might,
you know,
oh,
this is it.
But that [inaudible] fear is supposed to be there.
Man.
That said,
part of what motivates you,
part of it,
what makes you work?
You know,
one,
one of the things I'm most excited about right now is that I'm about to release
my next special,
I'm going to film it on April 20th in Atlanta at the Tabernacle.
Nice.
Still available for the circle.
True.
First show was pretty much sold out,
but we're going to,
I'm going to film it,
I'm going to release it on the Internet.
And what I'm scared about is writing a whole new fucking act and who knows my
neck.
Dak might suck.
I might be terrible now.
I might,
it might not be able to do stand up without the weapons of the past.
I don't believe that's the case.
I'm positive that I'm gonna be able to write some new shit.
But Shit,
anything can happen,
man.
Anything can happen.
And that's that that keeps you honest,
that keeps you real.
You know,
if you're always going on stage,
you know,
killing with the,
these,
these pieces that you've written for years and honed to a razor sharpness.
It's like after a while it almost becomes like you just kind of like plugging in
and using tools.
Whereas when you're forced to write new shit and been forced to craft a new bid
and make it into something that's,
that's that you're confident in,
you know,
that you could really use on stage with 100% confidence and not go,
here we go.
How's this one going to work out?
What's that scary.
I'm scared of that.
I'm scared of that right now,
but that's good dude.
That's important.
You can't always be comfortable.
You know,
you gotta get up in the morning and run just to let your brain know that you can
do it.
You know,
sometimes I force myself to do a Hindu squats like out of nowhere,
you know what you do,
squats are um,
I'm up to 200 now.
I do a 200 of them in a row and I do it before I do any workout before.
No matter what I do before I do what I do,
200 Hindu squats.
And the reason why is I thought about it,
I was like,
God,
I hate doing these fucking things.
I hate them.
There are these body weight squats and you,
it's not hard to do one.
It's like really easy like breathe in and you like it.
You go all the way down your,
your heels come off the ground into a very deep bodyweight squat and then you
stand back up.
Well,
they,
once you start,
once you get to like 40 or 50 in a row,
it fucking sucks,
man.
It sucks.
Yeah,
it's your,
your lungs are burning and you have to keep taking these huge,
enormous deep breaths in order to keep the pace cause you get,
you know,
you're trying to keep the same pace.
And I,
I've started forcing myself to do them and to force myself to do them,
just to let my brain know that you're going to have to start doing,
just deal with it,
bitch.
Just stop.
Stop your fucking complaining.
You know,
just make yourself do it's time to do it.
Ready?
Go.
I don't want to do it.
I'll do it in them first thing in the morning before breakfast.
I'll do it before a workout,
but I'll just decide,
all right,
ready,
go.
And I just have to do it.
It starts off easy.
It starts off like,
shit,
I want to get off this ride.
You know,
I'm going three and four,
but once you get to one 75 one 76 in your fucking legs are burning.
If you get through that man,
the rest of the day's easy.
The rest of the day is nonsense.
It's all bullshit and it,
it puts things in perspective.
It puts things into perspective physically because a lot of the stress that we
have as far as like accomplishing things and as far as like needing to get
things done,
there's a lot of physical stress involved in that because it's sort of never
satisfied.
Our body connects stress and stressful activity to some sort of danger,
so our body connects it to physical activities.
The reason why you get pumped up with adrenaline is the reason why when you're
in an argument with someone,
you're shaking,
you're shaking because you're ready to fight.
Okay?
You,
you know that's what it's about.
You're not shaking.
It's,
Oh,
I was so upset.
No,
you're ready to defend your life.
That's what you're doing.
You know when people get an argue with someone,
my hands are shaking.
I'm so upset.
It's because you wanted to get violent or someone wanted to get violent with
you,
or you sent the possibility of violence and your body was preparing yourself for
it.
That's reality.
Yeah.
And in,
unless you blow that shit out on a regular basis,
I don't believe you think is clearly,
I don't,
I don't believe it.
I believe your body is designed to have a certain amount of physical stress and
if you don't instigate it,
I think you,
you can function but you'll be imbalanced.
I think it's just,
you can be just as imbalanced by not exercising as you can by being addicted to
cigarettes or beer.
I mean it's not as dangerous,
I don't think,
you know,
health wise.
But I mean I think you could be just as imbalanced by it just as out of whack.
Yeah.
I got,
I haven't been,
I used to exercise Brody check out.
It looks do.
That's hard to do man.
We were talking about this the other day.
What are those 35 pounders?
It looks like it.
That's hard to do man.
That uh,
under her press.
Yeah.
Now I was on Lexapro there.
You will.
You look like a fucking stud.
Look at you.
You look like if there was a,
a,
a Russian gay bath porn.
Yeah,
you would be,
the guy would come in at the end and just fuck everyone and looks like Joe
Rogan's brother.
Can I get back to that?
Of course you can.
What are you talking about?
It's physically possible.
You just have to force yourself.
Just have to force myself.
Yes.
Brody,
positive people.
That's why you were brought here today for this podcast.
Brody,
we're going to get you back.
Can I actually get back into that?
You know,
I gotta get back into that and I feel like I'm off Lexapro.
Do you smell?
I'm not on it.
I'm just on the Depakote,
which is like a lithium.
Depakote won't,
we'll keep me from like spiraling upward,
so it's just,
I don't have anything for the bottom.
Spiraling upward.
We'll like downward dog.
Downward.
Upward upward.
That's what a manic moment is.
Yeah.
So I'm,
I have to be on these probably for another.
You're a few months.
Do they diagnose you as manic?
Like what are they?
Will they say like,
yeah,
I guess you
said like manic,
bipolar,
bipolar.
Yeah.
It'd be an awesome stripper.
Bipolar would that perfect combination in a stripper manic.
Bipolar just likes to talk hard and get crazy.
They should just,
just indycar,
you know,
like really strong.
Endeca like couch weed.
But I think I'm closer.
I'm so focused on my career and I know it's not totally healthy but I feel like
once I get in and get comfortable with it then I can be myself.
Like Ah,
I can like,
cause I feel like I'm not and I've put that stress on me like that close where I
can not relax.
Maybe you relax but still then really go at it.
Manic,
bipolar Brody.
Yeah.
You know I,
but I learned from it,
you know,
I don't want to go back to the hospital.
Comics and strippers are very close.
Very Aros.
Very Fun.
They're the same.
Very close.
Very close in a lot of ways.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Strippers get the same sort of fulfillment.
That's why comics always show their balls and strippers always try to tell jokes
honey.
Exactly.
Nailed it.
Are Ya,
I got a retweet from Buck Cherry.
Oh wrap.
Cause I wrote,
I said that the buck cherry song crazy bitch is like,
uh,
the anthem of every failed relationship.
A very opinion.
Why,
why is that?
Brody explained to me that or explain to me why it's so,
so fun to fuck the crazy ones.
The Nice ones,
the nice ones that you want to settle down with and have a good time with.
They're not as freaky.
No,
they're not.
Right and not,
you know what I need to,
yeah.
I want to have,
I mean I used to watch porn just like the rest of everybody and I stopped.
Um,
I think that I'm just like,
after all this stuff happened,
I think the Depakote is sexual side effects.
I think my situation,
I'm coats killing you dunk a little bit thick.
So can you get off that gets some bone or gee,
well here's the other thing.
You're supposed to get off at tune.
Is that what's going on?
Yeah,
I'll be off it.
He said,
the doctor said,
when they put me on all this stuff,
I was at high dosages,
1500 milligrams of Depakote,
800 milligrams of Seroquel,
which is a sleeping pill.
Antidepressants,
like a chemical free diet.
How's your diet?
My Diet could be better.
Okay,
that's silly.
His diet is horrible right now.
That's silly.
Anybody that has any sort of problem with their mind that the first thing that
you should concentrate on is your diet.
You gotta,
you gotta give your body healthy fuel.
There's no way your body can function if it's pulling minerals out of your
fucking muscles and trying to figure out where to go cause there's no vitamin C
here.
What?
How do I make this?
How do I fix this?
Mother fucker was,
there's no B12.
I've got nothing going to get back to that.
And so I said,
I gave myself six months into the budget to stop all this.
I'm going to bullshit.
Just do it,
man.
Just write it down and fucking do it.
You,
all you need to do is just look at your situation and look at the things you
need to fix.
Diet.
Fix that exercise every fucking day.
Just force yourself,
man.
Force yourself and write it down.
Write down what your sets are.
Write down what you sit and write down every day.
Brody,
this is what you're going to do today.
Me,
you have no excuse.
It's not like you've got 15 kids running around.
You got a business you have to run.
You're not doing shit.
So the most important thing for you right now would to be for you to get
healthy,
right?
Just to wait.
Oh,
you should concentrate on dawn.
Don't do.
You don't need it.
He doesn't.
He's not fat.
But it's,
the issue is,
but he's wrong.
This is the issue is nutrients.
If you,
you don't have good healthy food,
your brain's not going to produce the proper chemicals.
You're going to feel depressed.
It's just a fact.
Yeah.
I have high insulin levels.
I am depressed.
Yeah,
you fucks with your blood sugar.
It's not good.
That's super bad.
And in fact,
that's what the guy that killed Harvey milk.
Do you know that guy is linky damn [inaudible] he,
they said that what his excuse is part of his,
uh,
you know what they actually,
I don't know how they justified this,
but they gave him a lighter sentence because he said that he was addicted to
eating Twinkies.
Yeah.
So he got like a ridiculously light sentence for murdering this guy.
And the idea was that his blood sugar level was so fucked up from eating
Twinkies that he made an irrational decision and,
and killed this Harvey milk guy once.
Yeah.
That was a crazy stuff.
But that just at least that there's any scientific way whatsoever that could
actually use that as a defense should show you how fucked for your body and that
shit all day is especially a guy like you.
I know I drink a lot of water more than I should when I was more than you
should.
Well,
do you worry about that?
[inaudible] I'm not wanting to draw.
No,
I'm like I said,
I know I'm moving back to the valley f one eight s and represented.
Just got to get back.
I'm in the process of moving.
I'm shooting this HBO project pilot.
We'll see what happens with it.
I'm focusing on podcasting.
Um,
you don't have to do with what we're talking about.
Why adding all this other shit to the conversation.
What's missing in your life?
It's missing your life is diet,
exercise,
fix that shit.
Let's see.
Start,
stop,
play cs places would help as well and just get back on.
Nice girl.
Not Pussy.
A nice girl.
If you want pussy,
we'll get your flashlight.
But Joe,
how come I'm not?
How come I don't have that drive to exercise like I did before?
Because you're lazy.
Just fucking do it.
Have a double espresso and do it.
Write it down.
Write it down and make yourself do it.
Like I told you,
I do these body weight squats.
I don't want to fucking do them,
but I do them because I don't want to do them.
Just make yourself,
you have to force yourself on a regular basis.
One of the things when I was writing my book,
which I stalled out on,
I've got to get right back on that shit,
but I've been busy writing stand up lately.
Um,
when I was writing my book,
I noticed how difficult it is sometimes to just start to actually just sit down
and start in.
The way to do it is just schedule it.
What happened?
Lost Them.
Microphone ever.
Sorry.
The way to do it is just schedule it at at eight o'clock today,
I'm going to start,
period.
Nothing else is going to stop me.
I'm unplugging the phone.
Everybody else can go fuck themselves.
This is what I'm doing.
And that's what you gotta do it when you want to do this working out thing.
When it comes to your diet,
just fucking,
just write it down.
I'm not eating any shitty food.
It's done.
Should I join a club?
The marines,
you think they'll take,
you know,
I could like entertain them in a positive way.
Check out curves.
Learn from me.
Can you do 10 chin ups?
Not right now.
And you can't get through bootcamp.
Why would train for it?
Are you comfortable in the locker room when you go workout?
Yeah.
Like you just walk around naked and every hole.
The one at crunching.
What's Hollywood?
Yeah.
Crunch with Hollywood.
I used to stay in Brooklyn
at golds.
Yeah.
The one on overall Santa Monica.
Oh yeah.
Hold on.
The one in Santa Monica is,
was so gay that there was a guy who uh,
was one of the managers at 24 fitness.
Yeah.
Just give a shout out to my friend Jack Manager.
24 hour fitness.
I want to go,
there may not be his name.
Um,
he was a really funny guy and he had gotten sent over to west Hollywood because
they had to,
a new straight manager had to take over because apparently there was just
rampant homosexual sex going on.
Does that happen at these clubs?
Apparently it was just like a super gay disco.
Like what the 24 hour fitness had become was like just gay dudes.
Just loved it.
It was perfect.
And you know,
they were allegedly,
allegedly,
again,
this is all second and third hand information.
You know,
people are telling him that and then he's telling me,
but did he would have to fucking hose down the benches.
Oh she is everywhere and frequently walking on dudes blowing each other.
Ah,
but for them how awesome.
Why don't I just let people know when they enter,
just let people know go.
You know when they want to join,
just specify that they have plenty of people there that can meet that change the
name of it.
Like 24 hour fitness gay.
Yeah.
Can I get a guest pass?
Simple too.
I just change it to 24 hour fitness.
Gay.
It's all gay.
You can work out if you're straight,
but guess what?
Some shit's going down.
Yeah.
All around you and you've got to deal with,
they have gay cruises.
So to them they're all excited about it.
That'd be awesome.
And someone had to come in and fuck that up and hose down the bench and kick all
the blown guys out of this.
I wouldn't want to walk.
I don't think I've seen that.
I would go to 24 hour in Sherman oaks.
I don't think I ever saw it,
thank God.
But the goals on coal,
it was almost completely guy used to have a whole bit about it.
In my act it was really ridiculous to get hit on like at a gym,
you know like guys would like guys would like offer you support,
you know,
like they would offer to like the spot you when you didn't need a spot.
No need whatsoever for a spa blatantly just wanted a dang his balls over my
head,
like blatantly blatantly would come over and you know,
and and and say,
do you know how to work this?
Do you know what you're doing?
Like weird sort of flirty way of communicating with you while you're,
while you're working out there and you're like,
Whoa,
this is what it's like to be a chick.
Yeah.
I'm not into that.
That's what happens at that.
It's still that happens.
Oh fuck
yeah.
Oh Hey guys.
If you were gay you would love it though.
I guess you would.
Yeah,
I guess you would imagine if you went to a gym and it was all hot chicks that
wanted to come over and talk to you while you're working out.
Well,
I've got to get my workout in.
Oh.
But I would talk to him.
Yeah,
I would talk to him.
You'd be flattered.
You'd be excited.
What if you wanted to get your workout in,
but you also want to know,
you know,
get your freak on and you went there and it's all,
it's like a movie every way you look.
This girl's a great bodies and they're all flirting with you.
Well,
that's what it's like when you go to a gay gym.
If you're a gay dude,
if you're,
you know,
if you're an in shape gay party,
it's a party protein.
That's good.
And they're actually exercising too,
hopefully.
Yeah.
And of course they,
they're having a great time and it's a good thing,
man.
For them,
it's a great thing.
You know,
I don't,
there's nothing wrong with gay Jim's man.
I fully,
I don't get it,
obviously because I'm not gay.
But if I was,
I would be fucking psyched if it was a gay gym.
Come on,
man,
that would be awesome.
If you're just some crazy freak,
you know,
and you show up at the gym and everybody's blowing everybody and woo farting.
Yeah,
it'd be fucking great.
Imagine that you going to engage him in disguise like with a fake mustache,
like,
no,
I'm not sure.
Broken.
Like I got makeup on my tattoo show.
Did they get blown before or after their workout?
So some guys say,
oh,
after,
after and get your work done in first.
Yeah.
It'll be so greedy and fucking,
you know,
don't be so hasty.
Get your work on him.
Get the,
let the flirt build up.
Joe,
are there.
He kinda uncomfortable.
No,
I didn't feel uncomfortable.
I'm just like,
I'm still thinking about,
I gotta get back in shape.
I'm going to do it.
Keep bringing it back to yourself.
Getting in shape.
Just do it.
Write it down.
Ready to tight every day.
Going to work out.
You have title bullets,
right?
You didn't throw them away.
Did you know I got him.
I have know what to do.
You know what to do.
Just work out.
Have you done,
what do you mean?
Getting back to a,
why am I not doing?
Why did all I,
is it,
I just want to know why you need someone to hold your hand.
Are you a man or your mouse?
Why are you sad?
I am a man.
Are you in control of your own destiny?
No.
I'm thinking it should because I'm off.
The Lexapro is at which causes,
I would imagine taking that stuff is probably not the best thing for years so
I'm off dry him off it.
Why think when you're on those things.
One isn't.
One of the hallmarks of these is that they make you sort of relaxed and
comfortable with the way life is now.
Like for a lot of people,
I think I had a friend who was on Zoloft and he was saying that what it did was
he didn't give a fuck anymore.
Like it relaxed him about it,
like things that used to bother him.
Now all of a sudden didn't mean shit to him.
Right.
But I was able to like focus and work.
Yeah,
like not those things weren't bothered,
which I was able to,
I was like,
don't you think that that would also take some motivation away?
Yeah.
Maybe it did.
So now will you look at your belly,
you know,
and you're like,
I don't give a flock.
I look at it now.
It's driving me nuts.
That's why it's,
that's why I want to get back to working out.
So why don't you am I fuck and my fucking Dick is shrinking up.
Whoa,
Brody.
That do I need to take nitric oxide?
You know what that is?
Your Dick is shrinking.
Yeah.
It's like getting smile.
I was like,
I got a prostate thing going on.
Why?
What's happening?
Your prostate's getting ingredients,
pulling your Dick back in its body.
Is that what I,
yeah.
I don't know.
Oh,
I thought that sounded like a real medical term.
Yes.
I believe,
you know,
my doctor,
you've known as much as a lot of doctors.
I'm not sure.
I think if you're a doctor and you know as much as me,
you'd be fucking fired.
I think you would make sense
as we focus that on.
Stop looking at my stuff.
Um,
yeah dude,
I'm sure this stuff would have,
but you got off the Lexapro and that's fine,
but you're on this other stuff.
What is this other stuff's supposed to do?
Just keep me from,
from getting manic.
Yeah.
If that happens.
And then if you get to certain point,
you're,
you're gonna slowly wean yourself off of this stuff.
Yeah.
When is that scheduled to do?
Um,
probably by the end of the summer.
Why don't you just force yourself to just get,
and it'll be off every shade,
be off everything.
Get in tremendous shape right now while that's going on.
Right.
Force yourself,
not do it slowly,
you know,
make sure,
do like 10 cleans,
10 clean presses,
you know,
like do like a,
a short,
maybe 15,
20 minute Kelly,
I need to join a gym.
Have you thought about drinking?
Don't need to do shit,
but maybe just get out and be around people and exercise.
Maybe Gold's on coal.
That's what you need to do.
Boil up.
Shaved down.
What's up?
I'm going to,
I didn't get your move.
I need to do it Joe.
Yeah.
Get around a bunch of gangs cause I'm feeling stress in my chest and I want to
learn to deal with it.
Yeah.
Dressing your chest.
Yes.
Is that your heart?
Were you ever a big drinker at anytime in your life?
No,
never.
I mean,
college I drank a couple of times.
Yes.
I mean I've,
I met a couple of times but you know,
I'm not a big drinker.
No.
Because I don't like to drink and drive and I,
you know,
I vomited a couple times in college.
I got hung over a couple of times.
I'm not into that.
I like pot.
I'm not anti marijuana.
I love pop.
I love alcohol too.
I just don't love what it does to your body.
But I love it.
I love getting,
I love a few shots.
Having some whiskey,
getting on stage.
Stop.
No,
but Joe,
you're giving me positive energy I need,
they're a positive guy,
bro.
I need to like get,
that's why I'm moving out of this apartment.
It's dark and I need to be around people.
I'm working on this HBO project.
That's stressful,
but I got to do,
it's stressful in a sense that there's like pressure on me to do this thing and
people were like listening to me and I'm,
I gotta do this set on Conan.
And have you been in the same apartment for a long time?
Six months.
Oh,
I'm moving out.
And it's a dark place.
It's a little dark.
The neighbors are kind of creeping.
I just went there.
Right.
I'd move out.
I like the valley.
I liked the vibe of the valley.
That's where all the porn stars live.
Yeah.
The valley.
So you know,
they talk to them,
they'll hook you up,
you're going to,
you could have like a sitcom,
you and a bunch of porn stars all in townhouses right next to each other.
Dude,
start going to school at our Karaoke with me.
I go every two cycles,
no notes.
Start us.
Yeah,
I want,
and then I want to be off this.
I just want to do yoga.
I want to do therapy.
I want to do and I want to do comedy.
Let me tell you something.
This is the last thing.
The world listening to this wants to hear the guy saying a bunch of shit that
he's gonna do.
I'm gonna do,
I'm going to do with no evidence whatsoever that he's actually going to do it.
Just fucking do it.
Just do one.
Just do it.
Don't talk about it.
But if you want my advice,
that's what you have to do.
Write it down,
write it down and make sure you fill that fucking list out before you go to bed.
There's a list and on that list,
one of the things is a bunch of fucking exercises and you don't go to sleep
until those get done,
period.
It's that simple.
You either do it or you don't do it.
Either fall your list or you don't.
If you fall,
you lists,
then every day you get your shit done.
If you don't,
you come up with a bunch of excuses.
Oh my feet hurt that day and I had a really big meeting the next day.
I wanted to make sure it was a tip top mental form.
Shut up,
bitch.
Just do it.
It's all,
it's written down.
Do your 30 minute kettlebell routine.
Do whatever the fuck you have to do,
but that's a part of your day.
That must be done.
Just like brushing your teeth.
Just like eating meals.
You don't forget to shit.
Okay,
you do it because you're supposed to do it.
Period.
Brody Stevens,
this is what I need.
I don't a brother.
My Dad's
got,
this is what other either bitch dessert.
You don't need to have a brother.
She's just start letting Brody hang out with you more often and work out with
it.
You should get him to
Jesus Christ.
I'm not a fucking Tony Robbins.
I can't help the guys constantly 24 seven I can help you a certain amount of
Brody,
but I think you've got to help yourself.
It's important that you get mad.
You got to get fed up and you've got to think that you don't have that much time
left,
but this is reality.
You don't,
yeah,
I mean how much,
what is 40 years?
That's what we both have.
We pulled it up about 40 years.
We'll let halfway there.
What is that?
That's a fucking blink of an eye.
Dammit.
A summer comes so fucking quickly and then the winter so quickly and it's
happening.
It feels like it's happening quicker and quicker every year.
There's no time to waste on [inaudible].
Yeah.
Fuck that shit for just write down everything you're supposed to do and do it.
It's that simple.
You must get an ethic in your head that you must continue to fulfill your list.
This is the list of things you're doing.
Period.
This is what I need.
Unless you're sick or you're injured,
I'm not chicken.
Don't get psychosomatic and create fake injuries or illnesses.
Good.
What does that mean?
How much,
what percentage of your motivation in life is related to sex?
Uh,
right now,
I mean,
I would say a lot,
but it seems like it's been,
you know,
I want,
yeah,
one,
of course I see.
I want to be with a good looking woman,
but I don't think about like,
I want to have sex with their banker.
I mean,
I do.
I see a girl with a nice ass.
I look at her ass,
I'd go,
I'd like to like put my face around it and had to,
can I say that?
Yes,
you can.
Of course.
I like a chick with a great ass,
you know,
on a good face and good skin and eyes.
Feet.
Yeah,
of course.
Do Lips.
Do you eat the ass?
Yeah,
I've done that.
Yeah.
He liked that.
I mean,
do you prefer,
prefer,
I don't know if I prefer it,
but it's fine.
Black girls.
Have you had sex with?
MM,
none.
Whoa.
I mean,
I think one may be one maybe,
but
tan are really dirty.
One.
Maybe.
Why?
Maybe I've been with chicks,
but what do you mean?
One may be when is you either didn't do you blacked out memory?
No,
there was like a,
I think she was a lady of the night and some guys,
this team we were goofing around.
I mean,
I did some dangerous stuff.
Did some dangerous stuff.
Yeah.
I played college baseball.
She was,
uh,
she was,
an African American Lady of the night,
meaning a professional sex worker.
I believe so.
Somebody had and we all,
we had a good time.
Oh my sous,
whoa.
I'm going to assume a mouth misuse.
Massage his penis with her mouth.
I like,
honestly,
you know,
like the white fair skinned light white Irish girls.
He'd like that tall.
Pretty like Nicole Kidman looking pretty Irish girls.
That's not bad,
but like a,
I don't want to say German type,
but like Swedish,
right?
Yeah.
You liked that,
huh?
Yeah,
but I don't think I have a chance.
I feel like we have no true,
so that's crazy.
You're thinking crazy.
All right.
Well then Brody Stevens,
you're hilarious.
You're a very funny guy,
man.
Yeah,
well you know me.
That's thing I think when they get know me will they,
I just keep doing it.
That's Brody.
We need to,
we need a form of management company and take care of people like you.
That's what we need to do.
We need,
yeah,
that's quad management and sin and start booking guys like Brody on the road.
Send them out.
Maybe that's who will steal Shandra away from Jeff.
I would only help my confident.
Maybe she'll just open up a side business with us.
I mean when,
I'll tell you what,
like the reason why I think it would work out a manager,
you,
you lazy bitch,
which is offering you a whole career in stand up comedy.
Like I don't want to do the route on once.
Snuggle on this game.
Big Noble.
Yes,
you can go into different cities.
You want to enjoy it if you do it every day.
I don't enjoy it as much.
I enjoy it when I,
when I work,
when I get things done and I enjoy all the fun stuff.
I like buffet of Pussy do nonstop.
But are there,
are there a healthy supplements and food?
The food will help with that kind of,
yeah.
Fuck all that nonsense.
The food will certainly help,
but there's a lot of uh,
sort of,
uh,
just mental masturbation that goes with,
you know,
sort of diddling around the idea of getting on a diet or diddling around with
the idea of getting in shape or changing your life or writing a book or anything
that we,
you know,
you put off and procrastinate.
This is,
there's a bunch of different things that you can start doing to distract
yourself with the bottom line.
For a guy like you,
there's like essential things that you need in your life.
You need to eat healthier food and you need to get in shape because everything
else will come from that.
If you're in good shape and you're feeling good,
you'll feel better about the choices you make,
you'll you,
your body will function better,
your mind will function better.
You won't be,
you'll feel better.
You'll feel healthier if you're your brothers.
I know I need to do it.
Yeah,
and I guarantee you that stuff you're on.
I mean,
if you can substitute that with Yoga and exercise and then if it's possible for
you to still be happy and still be content.
Yeah.
The Oh,
noisy.
I think it's your chair.
Really.
No,
it's not squeezed.
If he's playing the flute outside,
it's real weird.
I think there's some sort of a few winters you,
well,
it's weird because when we get folks that go on iTunes,
probably can't hear it,
but if,
if I get really loud or any of us do,
it cuts off.
Oh,
that,
yeah.
That's,
that's because it's,
it's built to do that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But it's,
it's,
that's weird.
And then sometimes you hear like a little weird something in the background.
I don't know what it is,
but we've got to walk you set up ladies and gentlemen.
Okay.
Look at this tape everywhere.
You know,
like it,
you know,
I was listening to some fellow podcasters and I recently just kind of,
I just decided to try it out.
And uh,
it's weird I think because I always think our quality quality's kind of Shitty,
you know,
here and there,
like it's duct tape together.
But then I started listening to some of the other guys,
I was like,
Oh shit,
no,
wait,
wait past that.
Well,
there's a lot of guys that just use like one of those big blue ball microphone.
Yeah.
And it's like half those sound right?
We did that in the beginning when the beginning,
man we,
we uh,
we like cut some USB microphone shit.
It was terrible.
This,
this is a great setup.
We very,
it's very,
there's warmth than that.
You've made this place warm,
you know what I mean?
It's like it's broken in and it's kind of cool.
We liked that fact that we're at the ice house to,
you know,
the ice house is just,
there's so much good vibes here.
50 years of comedy,
so many great shows that we've had here.
The people that work here are so nice.
It's like,
it's like a super warm environment.
When we come here it's like this is like home and I was like family,
you know,
everybody's hugs you here and shit.
It's a great place.
Pasadena,
a lot of history.
Great town,
great town.
I see some of these estates drive around and was like,
where are these big movie producers from like the 1950s used to live.
Dude,
this is like where apparently Pasedena explained by my friend Rupert who lives
out here said that would essentially it was created,
was a bunch of really rich guys wanted to give to get away from all the fucking
Hollywood nuts.
So all the Hollywood nuts,
like all the actors,
they would move to the Hollywood hills and get these crazy mansion in the
Hollywood hills.
And everybody else was like,
fuck this,
I'm going to pass it Dina.
Yeah,
they moved to Pasadena and they're essentially like an hour away from,
you know,
uh,
Lake Arrowhead and big bear.
And though these states up there,
man,
I mean,
just fucking crazy lawns like the Beverly hillbillies.
Remember the Beverly hillbillies,
you know,
when you saw it like the big fucking driveway and big circular thing in the
middle,
like Holy Shit.
Like that's Pasadena.
Like everywhere you,
there's a bunch of areas where everywhere you look,
it's like these incredible old houses from like the 1920s and shit.
There's something,
something bad ass about that.
But you can own a house that existed in the 20s.
Yeah.
These old,
uh,
just the history and it hasn't,
Dana's got ton of that stuff.
I know you,
you come out here.
I love the Rose Bowl.
You drive up in these,
uh,
it's just,
it's green out here.
You see the mountains in the background
and it's just far enough from Hollywood to not be completely infected with its
bullshit.
Exactly.
Yeah.
They're like more regular people out here.
You know,
you get more,
you get a lot of like,
you know,
just fans period that have come from anywhere.
But you get like the,
the folks that regular folks like the in town folks.
I just think there's like a per capita,
a slightly less,
a smaller hipster community.
Oh yeah.
There's like no hair.
There's like single digit hipsters out here.
Smaller actor community.
Yeah.
But if you want to raise a family,
be great.
Great.
You know,
San Gabriel valley out here in these,
uh,
I wouldn't mind living in a big house.
You want a big house,
Brody?
Mm.
Gotcha.
No big getting shit.
But big house.
More.
You gotta pay for people to maintain the house.
What is this economics one-on-one?
Brody,
what are we doing?
We breaking down that bigger houses and more expensive to these people.
You guys talk numbers over there,
aren't you?
He just fucking Christ proud of him.
I don't know what I'm gonna do with you.
Death Squad management is going to have to get you on mushrooms,
but we're not sure how you would respond.
I would respond.
I'm a good guy.
You'd give me stuff to play off.
I can do it.
I enjoy.
I know you don't trims.
No,
I mean I wasn't maybe.
Oh really?
Yeah.
So we need to get you on mushrooms,
but I'm not sure how they would respond with the stuff that you're taking.
Yeah,
I'm going to be,
I'm gonna.
If I'm gonna Listen,
I'm gonna be,
and I know you am I supposed to be [inaudible] Ghana,
but
I'm still detoxing and,
but I'm,
I'm adopting the positive things.
Everybody's detoxing every positive energy,
drinking water,
getting back to it.
Not beating
myself up.
Maybe I'm just self genetically a Po.
I mean,
it's in my system.
We've got to stop talking about this cause this is the homework.
Ready to blow their fucking brains out,
listening to one guy over and over again,
wanting to get his life in order on the air.
Okay.
All right.
Live and rehashing the same subjects.
Sorry about that.
It's cool.
But let me change the subject.
Yes.
Got Jokes,
jokes.
So lemon in my tea.
This says me,
this song I heard like two weeks ago,
like I'm addicted to this song.
Okay.
We'll and talk to you.
I know what it is.
Yeah.
And I,
I did it for you.
I played it for you.
And uh,
it's,
to me it sucks because I,
everyone told,
like when I tell people I like the song,
they're like,
oh yeah,
welcome to three months ago.
And I get,
they get,
you feel kind of bad that you're the last person to hear the song,
but then you go on youtube and it says 122 million hits on Youtube and you're
like,
holy shit,
it shouldn't be that far off.
The only thing
I feel bad of is when,
when you look at,
when someone tells you about something or you tell someone about something and
they go welcome to three months ago and you feel bad.
The only thing you should feel bad is that that idiot is your friend.
Right.
That's what you should feel bad about.
Some Moron who's like giving me a hard time for not knowing about some stupid
song.
Yeah.
What,
why would you feel bad about it?
Because I know,
I mean like my credit.
Like how did that get my internet credit?
How did that get passed?
I do want to take,
I think about is that I,
it's the video.
It shows this guy like standing naked and people are Eric,
he's getting painted on and stuff.
And I think what happened is I started watching,
I was like,
I'm not watching this,
you know,
just from,
from the,
well,
no,
because I'm in a,
I don't have the same Internet credit that you do,
but I don't know.
You didn't see it either.
Song.
There's no,
and so it's weird that that has that many hits.
So it's called s some someone that you use someone I used to show what's up mean
in an accrued and it's got videos and bay.
Anyways,
the cover has 76 million hits and the cover in my opinion is better because it's
pretty crazy how these guys do this.
She'll be on the cover,
we'll sell the say the name of the cover.
Hold on.
It's a law walk off the earth is what it seems to be the name of these guys
and it's a band in there.
They're holding on a guitar and the,
there's one man who at the very end there's a woman who's above him and then
there's another man who is above her and then another man who's in between him
and the next guy who's at the very end who just touches the guitar lightly and
this guy singing.
It's crazy.
They're all like working the music at the same time.
Closing those windows with just like missile command.
Yeah.
This is what this watching this right now is like all this sound that you're
hearing is coming from one guitar and the bears guy that asked the guy beer guys
tee shirts
and the drums,
like somebody tapping on the end of it.
It's a really cool song.
And I usually don't like listening to guys saying there's a lot of people have
been sending me a lot of guy singers.
Right?
I don't like listening to the guy saying,
yeah,
these guys.
I like the one guy in the very right.
He's just like,
hi guys.
I'd like to start with a little twinkle.
And then he goes,
where
are they from?
These guys?
You should Australia.
This is the cover band.
I'm not sure where these guys in the,
uh,
the other one is,
um,
what does the dude's name?
This is the hundred and 21 million.
It's the same as you.
Why would you he,
I think he's from Australia,
but go ta,
Oh,
here's the chicks thing and its mission.
Do you,
you said that you can go up somebody that you
[inaudible] don't be on Ellen.
Damn,
this is good.
And the right,
I can see it.
Brody,
they set you on the right?
Yeah,
the Bareness is fucking great.
This is a great cover man.
How'd they come up with this concept?
It's pretty amazing.
I just did it.
That's bad ass.
I think they just like money.
No,
they're just awesome.
What do you mean they just,
I mean,
have you seen anything like that and what the guitars like there's six people in
the guitar.
What does that band again,
where they call it?
All right,
so the original song is called somebody.
Somebody that I used to know by G,
that one that we were just watching what is called,
I think the band is called walk off the earth.
But if you just,
you know,
youtube eight,
Google it,
you'll see the guitar and you see all the people lined up on the guitar
together.
It's fucking awesome.
And I'm sure 90% of the people are screaming at us now.
Okay,
so behind set,
let's talk hamster dance.
There's this website that,
why is it that people around forever feel like they,
uh,
I mean,
what is the push and the push just for more information or do the everyone is so
excited over the newest,
latest,
greatest shed that there's like an extreme backlash if you try to introduce them
to something they've already seen.
Like woo over dude saw three months ago.
Yeah.
Like there's like a,
like a righteous indignation about what,
how they're saying it though.
It's ranking systems,
right?
But what do you see you've mints but already achieved that.
I think that is that there's something that the universe is trying to do and
that the universe has the Internet in place so that people become more and more
fascinated by the constant influx of new information and new ideas and new songs
and new movies.
And Nunez knew that and it's like,
it's adding to the incredible amount of information that comes into your life on
a regular basis.
So it's moving forward.
Whatever technological achievements that we're,
we are accomplishing at a staggering rate or this crazy exponential rate.
That's why people are so addicted to the newest,
greatest shit on the Internet.
You know?
It's like there's a purpose to that.
The same reason why,
you know,
bees will go to a flower to get pollen,
you know?
But do people remember this stuff or is it just like in a three months it's
like,
yeah,
let's move.
Moving on to the next thing,
man.
The most important thing is just more shit.
More Shit.
It be exposed to more shit.
See the craziest shit possible and keep going and stuff and more stuff to your
crazy consciousness stuff and more shit to your memory.
Newest,
greatest,
keep moving.
Yeah.
It never stops.
Never stops ever until we blow up the fucking universe.
And that's a great thing about youtube and the Internet.
Just you just,
just fuck.
Yeah,
spoonfeed at boom,
boom,
boom.
Fill your head,
fill your head,
educate all that stuff.
Yes.
Brody,
now are they making money off that?
Like 121 million hits?
That guy got on that one does seven ad.
Oh,
I didn't have an ad,
but I'm sure now that he's probably,
I bought his CD immediately after hearing that song.
I D I think that's at least helping them.
Yeah,
it's pretty good.
It's pretty good song.
And like I said,
I don't usually like listen to the dude's.
A lot of people have been sending me dude bands not really into the dude's
singing about love.
Yeah.
Some of them.
Some of that sounds like horse shit to me.
Boy.
I like it.
It feels this weird eighties whole that that would like sting that,
that sound of the 80s that you use,
you know,
growing up in the 80s listening to that kind of music and nothing's really like
that anymore.
That's good.
So that,
that really kind of set off like an old sting or right lens or something like
that.
Yeah,
you're right.
It does have that sort of a authentic 80 sound to this.
Definitely.
It's funny how there's sort of like a sound of different errors.
There's a 60 sound,
you know,
there's uh,
a Beatles and then the,
uh,
Jim Morrison and Jimi Hendrix and there's a sound to that man.
It's,
it's fascinating that you hear like some songs like Steppenwolf,
you know,
magic carpet ride here,
shit like that.
And you're like,
oh,
that's a,
you know,
that's a sound of an era where their errors,
like where they considered music was like a down period probably 80s,
the 80s.
It was like,
it was all a joke,
right?
He's,
a lot of people felt like hairbands and poison and all that kind of shit.
A lot of people thought like,
what the fuck is going on man?
We went from led Zepplin to a poison like forward.
We're supposed to be moving forward.
Nothing sending wrong poison.
I like it.
A lot of their songs,
but then nirvana came along and put the fucking Kabash on all that shit.
As soon as they heard something real again,
everybody was like,
whoa.
You know,
when you heard something real and intelligent and raw,
when,
when a teen smear,
when smells like team spirit came out,
boom.
I remember I was thinking like,
this is the death of all of that nonsense.
Hairband shit like this.
No one's going to listen to that anymore.
It was over a buddy's house and he played it and he actually said this.
He goes,
dude,
I never heard nothing like this is a Boston guy.
Yeah,
dude,
I never heard not in like this.
Listen to this.
That called Nirvana and he plays and I was like,
whoa.
Yeah,
they're explosive.
Oh,
there were just,
yeah,
the whispering and then the loud chorus and the screaming,
screaming,
rape me.
What?
Yeah,
just,
I mean
there's just some powerful energy to what that fucking guy was doing.
How's co it was,
he was amazing to watch,
like grow up,
like,
like he would have red hair on Saturday night live or something.
Like,
Holy Shit,
he's such a bad ass.
He was a wild motherfucker and it's so horrible when you find out that he was so
depressed and unhappy.
Yeah.
It's one of the saddest things ever.
It's like you,
you,
you see this guy and he's like one of favorite musical artists
ever.
And then you realize that even though he was producing this amazing music is
life was just a hundred percent wrecked.
It should have been on Lexapro for us.
Maybe not man.
You know,
maybe there was some other,
there maybe there was like a real imbalance,
you know,
maybe he uh,
could have been solved.
There's something but maybe the without that maybe would have never made that
kind of music.
And I,
hi,
I wonder what the fuck that's all about man.
How something that can be so bad for the host.
Like a,
almost like a mental illness of depression can be so staggeringly good for the
people that can appreciate the art form that comes out of that stress.
It's almost unfair is it?
Well it is unfair because,
you know,
look,
if you really love Kurt Cobain and he really loved his music,
you would want them to be healthy.
But guess what?
If he was healthy,
that fucking raped me songs and never been written,
you know,
it smells like team spirit mean that has shit came out of agony and pain.
He and the fucking video when he's jumping around and singing that and like,
Holy Shit.
I mean it was just like,
it was so powerful.
It just,
it was just all electric.
Like the whole fucking resonance of the imagery in the,
the,
the sound of the song and the dancing and everything.
It just boom,
like hit you.
Like there's a force behind it.
I don't know if that would have existed,
if he was a happy person.
They be more like the unplugged I CD,
which was great.
Yeah,
it was great quotes.
I'm pure,
purely speculating obviously of course.
But I,
I really do.
I know so many people that have come from fucked up places and because of that,
they're so good.
Right.
It's weird,
man.
It's really weird.
But as you,
Laura,
you,
they learn to deal with it,
you know?
Yeah.
Well they have a massive amount of creative drive and motivation.
A lot of them because of whatever was fucked up about their past or whatever's
fucked up in their mind,
you know,
whether it's a mental illness or an imbalance or whatever you want to call it.
Yeah.
You know,
but a guy like Kurt Cobain,
man,
I mean that shit that mean that was just,
hey,
no one's found this room before was like he kicked open a new room of culture.
It's like culture is a giant mansion and well we already had this wrap room
going on and no people are advancing that sort of,
that sort of genre.
But he like kicked open a new room,
you know,
and I know there's a whole grunge scene going on in Seattle,
but uh,
he kicked open and,
and,
and how,
how obvious is it?
Seattle is depressing as fuck.
Seattle is so rainy and they always tell you,
hey,
it doesn't bother me.
Doesn't bother me.
I was there for four days and it bothered me.
Okay.
It was only there for four days.
And I was like,
where's the fucking sun?
I live in California.
You become a son junkie.
Yeah.
But to have so much brilliant,
beautiful emotional pain,
music come from some place where it's never sunny,
you know?
I mean,
Duh.
That was Ohio 75% of the time.
Almost say it was awful gray skies every day.
It sucks.
Yeah,
and you don't even,
you just become a,
you don't want to leave the house.
She become like,
hey,
let's just drink and get drunk and not think about how crappy it is today.
Think about how many great bands coming from Ohio.
You know black keys,
breeders?
Yeah.
Honey,
honey,
Suzanne,
she's from Ohio.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
She's got a song Ohio on that.
Billy Jack CD.
If you haven't heard about honey honey,
go download our podcast with them.
They're cool as fuck.
There are new best friends.
There are besties and they're on the road right now and they might be in your
city and they just released some new dates.
Go on their website,
honey.
Honey,
band.com if you go to honey,
honey.com what is it is like honey honey,
band.com site.
I think honey honey is a gay porn site or something like that.
Or at least porn.
Yeah,
I told him he should try to buy that but it might be too late.
Yeah.
Cause as they get more and more popular,
honey,
honey.com is probably gonna be more and more popular as well.
Well chocolate honey.com is definitely,
oh,
that's porn.
Yeah,
it's definitely Brian,
you've been hanging around with a lot of porn stores lately.
I'm worried about your buddy.
I'm going to be okay.
I'm going to become a part of the industry.
Are you?
You're not going to start filming.
Uh,
there's,
you know,
I've always counting,
somebody already said something the other day about how you're not somebody
until you have like a naked photo that's out there or something like that.
Girls,
you know,
like,
hey ladies,
you know,
it was a joke.
Oh,
trying to get them to have a picture.
Exactly.
So I was thinking about it the other day.
I was like,
thinking how many people I know have certain things and uh,
it's getting worse lately.
So yeah,
I could see myself getting into porn very quick.
Really?
You think so?
There's not the stigma that you don't think I would wonder.
I wonder if you just released a porn for a little,
like five bucks.
Well let's think of Louis C K method for poor while watching this stream ate
shit and it's like my free cams.com shit.
It's really fascinating.
It's a,
somebody told me about that.
I think it was,
you actually told me about my free cams and I just started going there.
It's,
it's,
it's addicting,
right?
It's crack.
Well I went there when I,
first of all,
I went there on an edible and I was,
I was sitting down in front of my computer.
I've been writing on edibles lately.
I like doing that.
Yeah.
I like riding on edibles because edibles are the best to like come out of the
tank,
like edibles,
hit a peak,
getting the tank,
get the ideas show jump out.
But I got fucking jacked on my way to my Microsoft word processing program by my
free cams.com I clicked on the link and I was,
I was so high and I was like,
what is this?
I was like,
this is some crazy interface I'm looking at literally pay,
if you haven't seen it folks,
it's,
I don't know how many windows are open at the same time,
but it has to be hundreds.
Yeah.
Okay.
There's hundred pages deep,
usually hundreds and hundreds of girls that are online naked in front of the
cameras and I just sit there and I just go,
what is this?
So I click on one boom and it's a girl and she's smoking a cigarette and she's
got a finger in her ass and I'm like,
this is the most ridiculous shit I've ever seen in my life.
And there's one after another after another and I'm like,
this is the old looking girls.
Some were amazed everybody,
but then I guess they make money off of it by they lure you into a dark room.
Better is the people that are not high is that scary ones.
The ones that's like that woman 70 years old and she's weighed 500 pounds and
she has a three cigarettes in her mouth in a lot of those too.
Well if you go to a porn site,
a lot of them,
they'll pop up a cam site in the background.
Yeah.
And then all of a sudden you hear,
oh you like that?
Yeah.
And you have to pull your window down.
Go,
what is this behind my,
what have you gotten here?
It's new browsers opened up as a girl,
you know with your shitty tattoos and assets and yeah,
a lot of extra skin and,
and some of them are hot.
It's a lot of them are hot,
but a lot of them are not.
Some of the weird ones are the ones from like West Virginia or something like
where you could tell like that that's her dad's bedroom and he's like passed out
drunk on the like on the floor.
That's the scary one.
Yeah.
There's a lot of them where you can tell they're in trailers.
Absolutely.
Tell them trailers and these girls are making money.
That's right.
Yeah.
Apparently that's a lot of porn stars do that now too.
One of them I was on the other day,
it was a Jill Kelly was on it.
You know Jill Kelly is,
yeah.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
what is this Sammy Road?
I see they sit in front of the camera and then they talk to their fans and you
know,
the guy's like,
hey,
are you think you get a lick your finger and touch your butt for me?
What's up?
And then I guess they have to give him money to do that.
Yeah,
well some of them just do it for free.
But what's really funny is like when some of them do it for free.
Yeah.
Like,
like,
like you'll just go and have half of those rooms are just completely naked.
And I girls like,
like holding up the dildo going,
I'll fuck this for 20 minutes and then here's the sample and just shoves us huge
thing in her.
Oh yeah,
see I'll do that if I get $100 and then,
oh,
and then there's other ones where they,
it's just ridiculous stuff.
Like,
I'll show you one boot for $1 or two boobs for $2 I will put this broomstick and
mighty,
but for $10 it's,
it's fun,
man.
It's,
it's weird.
It's very addictive.
It's just weird to get in contact with so many different people that you would
never be in contact with under normal circumstances.
The ability to just instantly be in,
uh,
West Virginia trailer.
Right.
Just like that.
And you are watching this woman and she's fucking yelling at her dog and the cat
jumped up and look it over and over that video that you did with little Esther,
that's how I,
you know,
it's like a real life version of that.
Yeah.
But you guys did that was a parody of something else,
wasn't it already have another,
yeah,
this other,
there was a video with this girl where his dad in the background was freaking
out because somebody said something to her,
her video,
like on Youtube,
like I said some things and then she was crying and the dads and background,
like if I find you and blah,
blah,
blah.
And so I parodied that V,
I forget the actual name at the video,
but wow.
I could show it to you in a second.
Yeah,
that was funny.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's a Lotta Lotta angry fucks out there online Brody.
Yeah.
I mean it's a whole new,
it's a whole new world.
I mean,
we're still is there,
are we,
there's a learning curve on all the shorts.
Yeah.
Are we almost,
there is a,
right now it's unfair because the women are sitting there and there's a camera
on them and then the men could be fucking killing rabbits while they jerk off
and the woman doesn't see anything.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
I mean,
the man could be fucking snapping a kittens head as he,
you know,
he,
orgasms while he's watching her video and she has no idea.
She's like,
well,
you guys have been awesome.
We want you to know he's killing hookers in front of her.
You know,
who knows,
who knows what's going on on that end.
Eventually,
that's not gonna exist.
Eventually when you have
communication with someone like that,
it'll be like in an interface,
an interface,
you know,
just how like for the longest time,
look at it this way.
For the longest time people had to have a television station or a movie to get
an idea across.
Like if you wanted to have a television show,
if you wanted to tell a story,
unless you wanted to write a play,
if you want to tell a story and have it broadcast in front of the whole country
or the world,
you had to have uh,
a television studio to do it.
Yeah.
Now we all have email.
We all have Twitter,
we all have Facebook and you can pass information almost instantly if you put up
a picture.
And it's so absolutely hilarious that I have to send it to my friend.
And so as in,
and then it keeps going back and forth and back and forth.
What are you doing Brian?
Is that the,
uh,
the real video?
Here's the real video.
My daughter,
does that even look like little Esther,
right?
Anymore your comments should put on there.
I'm recording them all when they are being to the police department.
You worry males will be caught and will be bound and go,
shit,
you're going to beat my daughter up.
You will have to deal with the politics because you've done good
duck,
duck goose and it gets really intense where him and a woman
scroll up my computer again.
Your p
three mustache.
So amazing.
I know my daughter
will never be good shame.
Y'All lie.
And what's your breath
like this
about me?
So yeah,
this is awesome.
Wow.
Well you know,
if you haven't on a normal scene life in your,
in your forties.
Oh you are.
You don't run into this Brody Stevens.
So you need to have the Internet just to have you connected with these people.
But I think what I was saying was eventually we're all going to have like our
own channel.
That's what it's coming down to.
What's coming down to,
you're going to be able to create almost anything thinking about the,
the,
just the,
the graphics that people can create now and do it.
And,
um,
you know,
there's a bunch of different three d image processing when people can make
essentially make their own video games they want.
Yeah.
There's a lot of different video game engines that you can actually even like
there's free demos of them and shit.
Kay Bryan,
this is distracting now,
but I think eventually everyone's gonna have their own channel.
I think,
you know,
it's just going to be like you have your own Twitter page,
you,
your,
it's going to,
there's going to be an even more emerging into your life and that's a good thing
I would think.
Yeah.
Brian,
you have the thing playing in the background?
No,
I took it off.
Oh,
just topped off now how dare you.
And then we'll funny and talented people are just regular people will be able to
be,
how the fuck do I know this might be the end of humans,
Brody,
who knows?
We might become something different.
We might interface with computers and be Borg's.
That can be real shit bunny.
Come on.
They have tattoos that go off when your phone rings.
Yeah.
The fuck is that
technology kind of weird like the Internet and all that has changed the game for
everything.
Of course it has.
So I'm,
I'm,
you know,
we're figuring that out and it's,
so this is what you do.
You've got an iPhone.
Yes,
I do set an alarm clock every morning,
set it every morning and that's when you wake up and work out.
So use the,
use the technology,
embrace it,
fill your head with it,
embrace it.
Brody,
do you like working out in the morning?
And I am not a fan of it.
That's why I do it.
It seems like I need to do it so I don't want,
because I don't like it.
That's why I like to do strength and conditioning in morning.
Fucking hate to do it.
So I like to do it forced myself,
Brodie.
And then you get a,
how many hours did you sleep at night?
I got to get at least eight.
And you get those eight hours and make myself do it.
And then what about when you're doing stand up on the road,
you still use affect your sleep.
Why won't you have to get up early?
You're doing stand up.
That's impressive that you'd get the eight hours and need it.
You need it and it's not negotiable.
You body has to rebuild itself.
If you don't get it in a night,
you got to get it during the day as a nap.
You gotta get something cause he a fuck yourself up.
Especially if you're working out,
you'll fuck yourself up.
You body has to have that downtime.
Yeah,
I get my sleep.
I've always been a good sleeper.
Luckily I feel like you never have a problem sleeping.
He never know.
Take anything.
[inaudible] that's,
that's,
that's where it gets tricky.
I got a lot of friends that are addicted to sleeping pills.
I got a lot like I know,
I know several people that have had real problems with sleeping pills.
Yeah.
Knock on wood.
I haven't had though.
I haven't had that problem.
Do you ever take them Brian?
Saving posts?
Yeah.
I'll take them once in awhile,
but I don't like it because I don't like being hung over the next morning and
they,
they tend to have that were like the first two hours I'm awake.
I'm just groggy.
I don't like that.
And so I don't,
I don't,
I'm not a big,
the only time I ever do sleeping pills is when I like,
yes,
I need to make sure I fall asleep and have at least eight hours of sleep
tonight.
And he used to take muscle relaxants.
He used to take that when he would be on flights like so he could go to sleep
and he didn't put two and two together.
He was doing like a Jujitsu seminars.
Yeah.
So you take these muscle relaxes and then he would go roll the next day and his
muscles would be wracked like you would gas out immediately.
He was constantly getting injured and then he finally put two and two together.
Like,
Whoa,
you're not supposed to do Jujitsu on muscle relaxants because essentially that's
what he was doing.
It was like staying in his system and he fucked his back up once.
Hard doing that.
Wow.
Yeah.
Cause that stays in your system for a couple of days.
It actually pulls the nitric oxide out of your,
out of your muscles apparently or mine or not.
I might have just made that up.
That might've been something somebody told me that I didn't research it all
nitric oxide and no,
that's good for your upload all that stuff.
Yeah.
It's supposed to be,
you know,
a that three.
What does that Jack Three d that's I think that's also on nitric oxide
supplement.
I like that stuff.
I had such great before you left if you want to do just like regular lifting,
you know and you'd do that in the morning.
You wouldn't do that and you don't take that take stuff.
But when you,
first of all I liked,
I like to do,
um,
like a light workout in the morning is one of my favorite things to do because
if you,
if you get used to doing like real hard workouts like kettlebells or something
like that,
like something really brutal.
Then just doing like a set,
like a regular set of press and dips
or something like that.
It's like so easy to do in the morning cause it's not,
it's not that intense.
Whereas you know,
it would be hard to motivate yourself for a workout like that.
If that was like the most intense he ever got.
Like God,
I don't want to lift.
But when you're used to doing crazy shit,
like an easy day of just doing bench press and dips,
that's it.
It's easy to do first thing in the morning before you get going,
knock it out.
Yeah,
just do that and do a few sets of that.
Just a couple of different exercises and it's better than doing nothing,
you know?
And,
and it might only take 1520 minutes.
You don't need much,
you know,
and you need to dip bar and,
and some and just do that consistently on a consistent basis.
That's the most important thing is consistency.
Making your body consistently have to work and then everything will just fucking
start getting stronger and you know,
your heart rate will drop and you'll start getting in shape.
You don't mean Michael Come back.
Yeah,
I needed to come back.
Joe.
It's in my head and said,
oh,
we'll then take some pills for it.
Take some Viagara fucking fire.
Right back to life.
I'll tell you what I feel like.
Yeah.
I like,
I am relaxed and I got to find that right thing.
I'm just going to like change my mind.
I'm changing my brain chemistry.
No.
Okay.
I'm doing it right now.
It's done.
But I,
that's why I love doing the podcast.
I don't want to get all sappy,
but all the twitters,
all the desk squad people,
they give me confidence.
They helped me.
They make me believe that what I'm doing is the right thing.
I think the podcast for you,
it's very interesting because it's almost to me like therapy,
you know,
you get to hang out with me and a couple of friends and just talk it out for two
to three hours straight where normally,
you know,
for that Coffee Cup I might say hi to you for like 10 minutes,
but by walk away and go do something else.
You know,
I'm not going to continue engaging in,
you know,
what your deal day is and does to that depth and detail.
You know,
I,
these podcasts have really helped me out.
I love coming here.
And then you get into Improv with Joey Diaz,
you know,
Greg Fitzsimmons yourself and then you go and do these shows.
It's like,
wow,
I love doing them,
you know,
and it's like does give me a help my confidence and all that and all the fans.
Yeah.
And I've already,
how do you respond to the criticism that you always bring every subject back to
Brody?
Uh,
sometimes I do.
Sometimes I don't have,
it depends on the setting.
Um,
I mean I can talk about,
do you ever talk to friends and give friends advice?
Are you an advice giver?
Yeah,
if they want it,
but I don't go out on my way doing it too much.
Who's the last person came to you for advice?
Who came to me for advice?
I've had a couple of comedians back at the comedy store.
Like to give,
given advice.
Yeah,
I'm okay.
Especially if somebody asked me,
you know,
it was fascinating,
the people who are super good at given advice for their lifes of mass.
Oh thanks.
Like fat on cigarettes all fucked up.
This we need to do this is what you just got to listen to me that
no I didn't,
I just thought you right.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm saying,
you know how they do force on you,
the people who want to force yeah.
They don't get it.
They haven't done it,
you know,
they don't,
they don't follow their own advice.
Looking at where people come up to you after shows and tell you what you should
have done.
Uh,
I haven't,
I haven't gotten that recently ever.
Um,
I got,
I mean a couple of little things.
We get that Brian,
we're guys come up to you after your show.
Yeah,
of course.
But it's usually like more just like that one shit was really good,
but what would that one thing about that weird,
you know,
not like saying you should stop doing that,
but kind of like,
all right,
he's telling me and like a backhanded slap.
Like you definitely thought that shit was weird,
you know,
and he didn't like it or something,
you know?
Yeah.
You got a lot of weird jokes on.
You got a lot of bits where I have to leave the room.
Really.
I get that.
What's but what's wars getting ignored?
Would you rather like have somebody be ignored?
What's worse?
Getting fucked by a rhino or a leopard.
A leopard,
Lee.
Sure.
Scratch,
you know,
the Rhino has a bigger,
bigger cock so the rhino would hurt more.
It's basically the same question you just asked me.
Okay.
No,
I think that,
I think for me,
when people don't know me and I have not bringing it back.
Gosh dangit yeah,
well we're talking about like what was going on with doing that,
but you gotta be aware you're doing it well.
It's going back to a question.
Oh,
I understand.
Most people are pretty nice to me.
After Shirley said,
good job,
I'm happy with that.
But I,
I,
I mean fans are weird to get a,
like you ever go on like one of those like super critical blogs,
like a special thing or something like that and listen to something somebody
might have to say about,
yeah,
I've stayed off those comments after I did.
I did some earlier.
You know,
Brian,
I were talking,
we were,
I did some early podcasts for a long time ago and I got negative feedback and I
kind of like learned my lesson and then I also said I'm not going to get
involved in,
I just started out putting up more positive energy and I didn't want to uh,
get involved with too much internet craziness.
I don't Google my name and going to chat rooms,
Google your name and going into the chat rooms at two completely different
things.
How did you connect them?
Well,
for however much time you spend googling your name,
then you have to go to this chat room and you owe them some time.
I may get a Google alert,
I'll be honest,
but I,
it's usually you get a Google alert when someone writes a story about you or
something.
Is that what that says?
Something like that.
It comes out.
Oh my God,
I don't know.
Doing you have that also?
Yeah,
for deaths gone.
Oh Wow.
It's mostly just like somebody promoting a show and your name's in it.
Oh,
okay.
somebody might be like fake promoting some shit.
You ever heard someone say that you're going to be somewhere and you weren't
really as I was just trying to promote that big of a name yet.
I just like,
Hey,
hope that happen.
I just like heavy metal music and groups of terrorists Kinda guys.
That's the way to all my emails are about like heavy metal music and groups of
terrorists.
What do you mean?
Like I always get news reports like does the death squad out of Egypt,
you know,
and so you have it done and then there's,
there's like some band called death squad was like heavy metal.
There's a band called,
yeah,
it's like,
like there's a band called fear factory too.
Yeah.
When fear factor going on TV.
Why did they not just drop that name right?
Yeah,
the band.
Yeah.
I know you probably were fear factory first,
but dude,
come on you,
you've changed your name.
Exactly.
Aren't you glad you don't have to have a name?
What would you be if you a band?
Fewer
wa if comedy was like a band,
you know,
you can't say,
hey,
it's Brody Stevens and Joe Rogan and we're here to sing a song.
No,
you have to be a fucking band.
So if you are a band,
if every comic was like a band,
yeah,
it'd be tough on a mean band names that gotta be tough to come up with.
Kind of funny.
You know,
singers don't have to do that.
Like Sheryl Crow.
She can go on the road and be Sheryl Crow.
Yeah.
But you know,
I would like,
she can't,
by the way,
be like Raven Wolf craft.
She can't like make up a name either.
Joe And brode.
I buy bread,
Bro.
I been the bird street boy.
Broadstreet street boy.
But isn't that funny?
You know,
like,
uh,
if you,
if you're a one person and you make up a name like the queen of the world or
something like that,
you're a douchebag.
Yeah.
You know,
but if you're a band and you call yourselves the Queens of the stone age,
that's totally cool.
Yeah,
you're right.
It's weird.
My aunts and individuals,
it's a bands.
You've got to be a crazier lifestyle.
Oh,
fuck.
Yeah.
Well,
they have to say the same songs to the,
what's really sucks about bands when people don't want to hear new stuff.
Think about that.
You know,
we,
we have to do new stuff constantly,
but bands like,
there's,
there's certain pretty like,
people go to see rolling stones and the rolling stones,
we'll have a new song.
People go,
oh,
like roll their eyes and go,
fuck.
I think Bruce Springsteen's getting that.
I hear,
I read on a couple of his,
uh,
shows like he's doing a syllabus,
new stuff.
Ooh,
that sucks.
That's gotta be hard.
And people,
all they want to hear,
that's all they don't want to hear is they got to work in some new songs.
Yeah.
Well when you like a Kinison used to have a joke about the beach boys buck
seeing the beach boys after all the years and they had been like ever gone surf
and you could tell they were like hating it.
They didn't want to be singing in anymore.
They really do like these bands.
Some of them,
some of them are probably just happy.
They have a,
a fan base and the people want to come see him and they're,
you know,
the happy they,
they're making a living.
You know,
it's all depends on your attitude.
Look,
if you're,
if you're a band like the beach boys or something like that,
she could be bummed out too.
You have to sing the same songs.
Or You could go,
Holy Shit,
where the fucking beach boys,
you know,
think about that.
Not a lot of people get to be the beach boys.
We had created some iconic music.
They're huge stars for decade after decade and if they show up at some state
fair or some,
you know,
some theater somewhere,
people still want to go see them,
they're happy.
They'll create all that house.
I don't know if they're bit crazy the bat back then they probably became popular
because people lived in shitty places in the United States and they just wanted
to hear surf music.
They wanted to feel like what it was liked being California and you know,
cause that's kind of what their music kind of has a feeling for it.
Right.
When you say that,
that's probably why two of each culture.
Yeah.
So the beach culture is California was like,
you know,
you would see it in like movies and shit.
People driving around convertibles and surfboards on the top of their trucks and
Whoa,
mayor was clear.
No smog.
Beach boys are respected.
People don't realize how respected the beach boys are.
You know,
who they affected,
like the Beatles love dumb,
all those guys.
That's a good point about what it must have been likely being in Ohio and you
know,
looking at that shit in the 1940s or whatever the hell it was that they're
singing those songs.
They sing those songs.
Sixties fifties seventies sixties I think it was a 50s really?
Yeah.
Beach Boys.
I think that was the 50s hmm.
I'm pretty sure you know,
but yeah,
continue all the beach boys.
I slow it down a little.
I think people were stupid as fuck back then.
I think it'd be fat I'm course.
Sure there was a few incredibly brilliant people that were way smarter than me
now.
But I think for the most part,
people in the 1950s they were like children,
you know,
their,
their perception of the world around them,
you know,
and what it was like,
it was very childlike.
I think if I could go to one point in history and watch it unfold,
I would love to watch the 50s become the 60s I think that would that and
watching it in San Francisco,
you know,
and there during the,
the whole,
uh,
you know,
the asset generation and you know,
w what was going on back then were these huge transformation of the culture from
the 1950s to sixties.
What set that off?
Just like real serious shit.
Acid acid.
Yeah,
for sure.
Now more brow.
There was a lot,
Ken Kesey and the Merry Pranksters and Timothy leary.
You know,
Timothy Leary,
being a professor,
professor,
I think it was a professor at Harvard,
right?
And you know,
a brilliant guy,
he was a scientist,
so all of a sudden was advocating,
turn on,
tune in,
drop out.
He wanted people to take acid tune into the world.
They're living in and drop out of this crazy culture and society.
And they was saying that you don't need to,
you didn't need to do it like this,
you know.
And uh,
of course they locked him up
and that was all coming out of San Francisco.
I'm going to ask San Francisco.
It was all coming out of San Francisco and it was all coming out of grass.
People Smoking Weed and uh,
people doing psychedelics.
People became a more,
uh,
I mean,
there's the reason why I was the summer of love.
Okay?
There's a reason why it was,
you know,
this flower child movement.
It was the hippies and the flower children.
I mean that,
that's all love man.
That's all psychedelic enhance states of consciousness where these people had
reached this place where they felt connected to each other and loving each
other.
And this is like all the stuff that like turns Mckenna had hypothesized about
being the actual creation or the reason for the creation of civilization in the
first place is that civilization rose out of psychedelic experiences that these
are the,
these monkeys were having,
you know,
millions and millions of years ago and Graham Hancock believes the same thing as
well.
They,
they,
he points to the great explosion of art and culture 50,000 years ago.
Like how,
uh,
people from,
from a certain point in time to today,
there's been this unstoppable rise of like imagery in art and language and all
these different things.
And he points to it being one of the clearer cases of when people started really
using psychedelics on a regular basis.
Yeah.
I feel like we're at that kind of stage right now with what the Internet is an
apple and iTunes and you can do everything.
So we're like right there.
So it's either you're on board or you're not.
I feel like more people are on board.
Even conservative types or non creative types.
You know,
the iPhone,
everyone's got it.
Everybody's on
Twitter.
These aren't really,
I mean,
Facebook,
everybody's got,
yeah,
so I feel like,
well,
I think those are psychedelic.
I think the Internet is psychedelic.
I mean,
I think things that break down boundaries,
things that dissolve the boundaries between you and the rest of the world,
whether it's through information,
imagery,
video,
music,
whatever the fuck it is,
the feeling that you get from connecting to whatever art form they produce or
whatever words they put out there,
whatever news stories they send you,
that,
that energy,
that that is all very psychedelic.
It's all,
it's all changing the culture,
you know,
it's,
it's changing the way your mind works and it's,
it's forcing new information there.
It's a very different kind of experience.
But if it existed a thousand years ago,
man,
if you thousand years ago you could somehow or another take someone and then
bring them to this podcast and sit them in front of a laptop and explain what's
happening.
They would fucking shake uncontrollably.
They'd be freaking out.
They wouldn't even be able to wrap their hand around.
They would look at the fact that I'm watching our show on Ustream and then I
check my email.
Oh look,
Chris Hardwick's going to do the podcast,
and then I checked my Twitter and Oh yeah,
this guy's right.
I did say that wrong.
You know what I mean?
It's,
it's it.
This is incredible.
What do you think the first thing they would do?
Like Marin,
Moreau,
shit,
their pants.
What is this?
You mean you can't have the answer?
This is magic.
Where's it coming from?
They would go crazy if you could get Einstein,
man,
if you could take Einstein and he put them today and sit them in front of a
computer,
I guarantee you he would just have this incredible smile on his face.
He'd be like,
oh,
just,
oh.
It would be,
we'd be so fucking excited about this.
Yeah.
To us,
it just snuck up on us.
It creeped up,
Dennis,
to the point where we're just accepting the fact that it exists.
I mean,
this pot.
Look,
we,
we know the impact of this podcast.
Every time we go on the road.
This is the weirdest thing I've ever done ever.
Well we just for free put this stuff out there.
Just uh,
just a recording of conversations and it resonates with people.
Then they come to see you on the road and then you have like this whole thing
going on and,
and all this came out of nowhere.
It all came out of the Internet.
This is impossible.
Impossible.
50 years ago,
a hundred years ago.
All this stuff that we're doing is impossible and it's complementing the live
performance is a real energy to,
we're not,
you know,
the problem is when people are on the Internet 24 hours a day,
I mean you are what your iPhone of course,
but like going out and seeing people,
you know,
you gotta you gotta do both.
Well I think what podcasts do is it gives people an opportunity to really
interact with people about like complex subjects.
You know,
like we've had a bunch of different people on with a bunch of really different
interesting viewpoints.
You know,
some,
I agreed with some that I didn't agree,
agree with,
but to be exposed to that many of them.
And to expose these really open public conversations uncensored to expose it to
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of people.
Yeah,
I mean that's a,
that's a rare and unique opportunity and it's all happening because of this
fucking crazy intranet thing,
man.
And this is only going to get nutty or this isn't going to stay like it's gonna.
It's gonna somehow or another jump from this stupid box that you have to carry
around with to something that you can see in front of your eyes.
It's going to be like some sort of a lens that gets implanted in your eyelid.
I mean,
they're gonna figure out how to do that and have figured out how to get it down
and it's going to be no different than getting a tattoo.
It's going to be so normal.
People are going to get these inner inner faces with a lens and you're going to
be able to look.
They've already designed them.
You can look through it and seek text on it.
You'd be able to communicate with it through Siri will be able to pull up
websites for you,
show you images,
or should be able to show you video stream you realtime movies.
You're going to be a little watch movies on your fucking fake eyelids.
Chris Brown's taxi would be like that,
like on your eye.
Exactly.
But is there a time where people are going to go?
That's too much.
Like,
of course it is right now.
They're doing it misses those.
The Unabomber was saying back when he was,
uh,
wanting to kill all those people when he was going crazy and killing all these
people that were involved in technology.
He was,
he thought that human beings were aiding and abetting an enemy and that enemy
was technology and that you,
you,
these people were doing it and it was,
uh,
it was against the human race and he was completely fucking nuts.
But if you look at it and you go,
well,
where's this gonna go?
How,
where's this going?
I mean,
it's only going in one direction.
It's going more complex,
more crazy,
more invasive,
and more.
We're digging into each other's lives more.
We're connecting with each other.
Just the Facebook shit and people tagging your just to start,
just to start and tweeting and retweeting and you know,
all this stuff.
It's,
it's,
it's connecting people together more and more and more.
And right now it's just text and then you can control a more and more.
I think it's going to,
somehow or another it's going to make a leap from texts to the next thing and
that's when Shit's going to get really weird.
But I don't know what that next thing is.
You know,
I don't think it's video.
I don't think it's as simple as you recording video and you distributing video.
I think it's going to be some sort of a streaming image,
sort of a technology,
sort of like a facetime type of a thing.
But like the neck level switch,
it's going to get weird.
I think the next level,
you know what it's going to be.
They develop these artificial lenses and they let you see through my eyes.
Right?
That's going to be fucking nuts.
Could you imagine you,
you tune into a guy's channel and you're literally living his life through his
eyes.
That'd be hi.
How fucking strangers that and not,
not even slightly impossible.
Not even slightly.
What if you couldn't stop it?
Like anybody could just be anywhere and just like,
ah,
I'm,
I hacked into Joe.
Let's see what's going on here.
Oh Damn.
That's a lot of poop.
Yeah.
What if you just broadcast it on Ustream?
I can.
Every channel on Ustream was like you looking in the mirror beating off.
How about that?
So who wants to do that?
People want someone for sure.
And then somebody will want to watch it and somebody will make money off it.
If you can think of it.
Somebody wants to do it for sure.
There's a lot of weird fuckers out there,
man,
but they can't do stand up.
Not many of them.
Uh,
right.
You know,
some of them can't stand up is a weird thing in it.
You can do it or you can't do it.
Some guys get better.
I remember,
I remember it.
There's a few guys you saw like that we're like open miker and you're like,
this guy's fucked.
He's never going to be able to just poor guy.
Yeah.
He just can't connect to it.
And then all of a sudden one day they sort of figure it out and then next thing
you know they're competent.
That's weird,
right?
Yeah.
You just keep doing it though.
Some people make it,
some people make it despite of themselves.
They just sort of figure out how to be funny.
I'd never say that.
Some people can't do it cause I don't know how the hell I did it.
Right.
You know,
I'm not exactly sure how you do it either.
You know?
I'll just do it.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Um,
I don't know.
I'm saying that other people can't do it.
I think they going to have to figure it out.
But that's the,
that's the,
you can never say that a person,
a mind,
a thinking human could not figure something out.
You know?
You just have to be fucking completely engrossed in it.
Whatever it is.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean,
I hear other comedians will say like,
Oh,
this guy has thousands of,
like it got tons of hits on the Internet,
he's popular on Youtube.
And then they start doing,
they start doing stand up and then people go,
oh,
it's not that great.
You hear that guys who make videos you mean?
Yeah,
yeah.
There's a lot of guys did like songs and shit and they made like funny,
funny little videos and they tried to go on the road.
I feel like if you're a stand up comedian and you're like,
hopefully you're like,
you think like a comedian first as opposed to a video guy.
Yeah,
you would think that.
But that's because you're like kind of a real comic and you're proud of being a
comic.
And you know,
I think a lot of us like Joey Diaz is very,
this very similar in this way too.
It's like he achieved his status as a comedian and he's proud.
He's like a gunslinger.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Like,
you know,
Joey Diaz,
have you talked to him about something and he'll tell you,
he's like,
I'm cause I'm a fucking comic.
That's how I do it.
[inaudible]
comic.
Yeah.
He goes like,
dog,
you're a comic.
He goes,
that's why all the,
you know,
Joey will tell you about like work.
Like he's just like,
that's where all these people can go fuck themselves.
They're like,
you can't get me to do anything I don't want to do.
I'm a fucking comic.
I got a job already.
You know,
I'm good at it.
I get paid well hand and he died.
And anybody does those videos too.
He does all that,
does everything.
He does everything.
But he's,
you know,
Joey Diaz will always do stand up.
Like he says,
what do we got Doug?
Where are we going?
He's always like,
he's always,
you know,
I can't do that fucking comedy and Magic Club with,
you're trying to get Louisville,
but I'm going to be headlining somewhere.
Headline to my area Improv next week.
So if you're in Miami and I,
if you are,
first of all move,
don't move until FTC.
Joey [inaudible].
I'm in my Miami soon too.
I'm in Fort Lauderdale.
Um,
and that's,
uh,
April.
What is it?
The 13th,
14th and 15th at the Fort Lauderdale Improv at the Hollywood improv.
The hard rock,
the Improv there.
You ever done that one?
Florida.
I've been there,
but I didn't do it fucking tremendous.
Next weekend.
And then Louisville,
Louisville,
Kentucky at the Improv in Louisville and this weekend,
Hermosa beach at the comedy Magic Club,
all gearing up for April 20th in Atlanta and a,
that's going to be at the Tabernacle and the dump.
I'm super excited about that.
That's where I'm filming my special.
So I'm writing a lot.
Brody.
I'm getting crazy writing.
I mean,
the group getting it out there,
you're just fired up.
I'm,
I'm motivated man.
I've been having these,
I did like an hour and 20 here at the Ice House the other night.
I'm having long sets.
Um,
I'm just,
I feel like when you,
when you really start working on something,
man,
he really,
uh,
get some momentum.
You don't want it to stop that good feeling of creating things.
It could feel
of like everything in that groove.
You don't want to stop.
You just want to keep going.
So that's where I am right now.
Fucking fire it up.
Prouty I want to see it time and I want to see you Saturday at my seat and
salads doing kettlebells.
What do you want me Saturday herb shops.
I want to see burpees before the show.
10.
All right,
I'll give you 10 hardcore burpees.
I'll give you those before the show.
What I want.
Like burp,
burp on his chest.
You know what a burpee is?
No,
it's a type of exercise.
Very explosive.
He dropped down into like a push up position up to your knees,
up,
up to your feet,
like in a squat position.
Then jumped to the sky,
hands up in the air,
dropped down,
push up position and you repeat over and over and over again until exhausted.
I was thinking of baby burpee.
Second know done.
Burpees.
I think that's burping.
That's called burping.
Um,
you guys have a show here Friday night.
At Friday night we have Doug Benson,
Joey [inaudible],
and a bunch of people.
Doug Benson.
Powerful.
Doug Benson,
buy tickets,
discover ideas,
but powerful.
Doug Benson wants us to do as podcast.
But you know what,
man,
I don't really give a fuck about movie trivia.
I love Doug Benson.
I love talking to him and I love having them do our podcast.
But you know,
when you start talking to like,
you know what movie was Karira MMM hmm.
And those are hard to hit that you want you to care.
Yeah.
That's his thing.
I mean this thing is,
it's a movie thing.
Doug loves movies.
I mean,
he really does.
He fucking loves movies.
Yeah.
But that would be like me having him on and only talking to MMA.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
I would do it.
Doug.
Brian will do it.
There you go Doug.
But we'd love you dog.
That's it.
I think the show's over.
Brody just fell asleep on us right away.
Yes.
Positive Energy.
You got it.
So when can we know if we see crazy tweets,
when can we know you're completely off of this new stuff that you're on?
When is this scheduled detox?
Uh,
like three more months.
Three more months.
Why do they have it planned out like that?
He takes like a year.
Oh,
you have to slowly do it.
Yeah,
he's cut back.
You know,
going out on your Luda.
Yeah.
You cut back slowly on your dosage.
Yes.
And then there's also a secret,
I heard that maybe like even the last couple of months that you were off at the
whole time they're sugar pills.
So you got to think about bad,
what they might be playing mind games with you.
Who's playing mind games?
The government,
the government,
the government's fucking with Brody said,
try to get to Zach Galifianakis,
alien teenage mutant Ninja Turtles.
We,
there's a bunch of cameras here,
man.
I want to explore.
There's a camera here,
one to explain what does his HBO Qbo Project.
I shot a pilot.
They seem to like it.
So we're going to expand on it and I'm shooting these episodes and it's a little
bit about me going into the next level,
you know,
out of getting out of warm up,
going to the next level,
becoming a stand up,
going on the road,
being more mature,
doing it.
And also just being funny
about this.
You're doing a show about it.
I think I may be.
Yeah.
You think you may be CD did a pilot and now you're just going to start shooting
shows and see if they like it.
Well,
there's scripts.
There's loose scripts.
It's based on,
there's one,
it's about me getting back into comedy.
I'm working my way back and I'm doing a set on Conan,
so I'm working my way back in from that.
We document a little bit of my,
uh,
my meltdown that I had and how you can
come back for many thing,
positive energy,
exercising,
getting back to the valley.
Then have some fantasy segments or some scripted comedy.
Talk to my mom.
We like you're writing like a Unicorn in.
Yeah.
What is going on?
Are you in Narnia?
Um,
what is it going to be called?
I think it's so far they're running titles,
all things,
Brody.
All things Brody.
Sounds good.
Yeah.
So keeping it generic,
be able to handle the waterfall of hot girls that want to have sex with you
after you become a television star.
Hbo.
Yeah.
I get your leftovers.
Can I be better?
You will be the next entourage.
Is that possible?
I'm not saying it's,
I mean it's possible.
I'm not saying it's probable,
but it's possible.
I suppose you feel it.
I'm feeling good thing sometimes wave wave about the wash over Brody and ways of
success.
I'm feeling that women's tongues.
Yes.
You could have a lot of threesomes or you're not going to do a three term thing.
I would do a threesome.
Do you think you'd get a driver or will you drive yourself around?
I thought about a driver right there.
Mansion in the hills?
No,
just make them.
Girls can like stay at your place.
They'll keep it cool when you're gone and a lot of them are homeless.
We'll ever sing in a townhouse in the valley.
Townhouse in the valley.
Dude,
you're going to have a mansion in the hills.
You're going to be on HBO.
You're going to be huge.
You think I can.
Why couldn't you would?
Where does Corey Haim live?
He's not alive and heaven cause he done.
Okay.
Bad example.
I gotta believe Joel.
I mean I'm unbelieving.
Yeah,
he's not with us anymore.
You've got to believe what I got to believe it.
And I do believe,
believe in love.
Yeah,
love is a good thing.
I don't listen to the news.
He believes me.
Um,
I know I'm fucked up.
I know I'm not perfect.
Who's coming?
Who's not fucked up?
Anybody who's not fucked up.
Isn't that interesting?
All right,
good.
Yeah,
and I'm channeling into comedy channel at Brody.
I'm channeling it and I'm telling you like you've been a big positive supporter
in my life.
I'm not kidding.
Listen,
man,
I don't think it's possible in this world.
If you're paying attention to not be fucked up because the whole world is
contradictory,
the whole world makes no sense.
We're in fucking wars that make no sense.
The war on drugs make no sense.
Politics make no sense.
Representative government make no sense.
None of it makes sense of special interest groups doesn't make any sense.
The amount of taxes you pay doesn't make any sense.
The amount of oil cost,
the fact that oil is the only way we've fucking power this whole thing.
That doesn't make any sense either.
What do we need to do when you run out?
None of this shit makes sense.
Brody.
If you are paying attention,
you gotta be a little crazy just to get through it.
You've got to be a little,
not to beat a little explosive,
a little,
just wanting to burst out of your fucking skin at every moment.
You pay attention to this crazy life we live.
You have to be fucked up.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
it's a fucked up world.
It's a fucked up world.
But we're in it and positive energy,
positive energy,
hard knock life for us.
And I'm following my instincts.
People seem to like what I'm doing.
So I'm doing it,
I'm learning it.
And you know,
wow.
Fall Brody's the Stephens Calgary.
Um,
I'm coming July 20th,
they just announced the UFC in,
um,
uh,
if you go to Joe rogan.net,
I'll tell you,
I think it's Jeff.
Get the Jack Singer concert hall.
Yeah.
And uh,
yeah,
and that's a tickets already on sale for that.
Tickets are pretty much sold out for New York.
New York is,
uh,
February 4th,
sorry,
bitch.
Now February,
May,
May 4th.
Yeah.
January 1st where are you playing in New York City?
Uh,
where am I am Brian?
the theater.
I'll get there that night.
I swear to God.
I love it.
Manhattan Center or something?
Yeah,
the Manhattans.
Yeah.
Manhattan Center in New York.
Big Place.
It's already sold out.
Um,
so,
uh,
thank you.
My friends in New York,
I can't wait to see it.
Yes.
I'll have a bunch of new material hollow.
Um,
so this weekend is the hurt modes of beach comedy and Magic Club with Duncan
Trussell our issue fear on Friday night and Duncan Trussell Brody Stevens on
Saturday.
Yes.
Positive next weekend.
Louisville at the Improv,
the weekend after that or whatever.
The 13th,
14th and 15th.
Not the weekend after that,
but a couple of weeks I'm at the Fort Lauderdale Improv and then for 20 Atlanta,
Georgia taking tape my shit at the Tabernacle.
Very excited.
I can't wait.
CanNot wait.
Thank you to the flashlight for sponsoring our podcast.
Thank you.
You know before thanked the fleshlight man,
thank you to all the fine people tuning into this because if it wasn't for you
guys we would uh,
it would be very sad if we all got together and we sat around and a and just
talked a lot of shit and then recorded it and then put it out there and no one
downloaded it ever.
That would not be fun.
What's fun is there's so many fucking people out there doing it.
We're going to get those.
Hello Brian or O'brian shirts made.
Oh Brian,
exactly.
volume one and two is out on youtube.
Yeah,
there's a volume two to yeah,
go look.
Go look.
O'Brian one and O'brien too cause they're pretty fucking funny.
Um,
thanks the flashlight.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link.
Enter in the code name Rogan.
Save yourself 15% off and a thank you to honest.com.
O n n I t use a code name Rogan.
You will get 10% off and please go to higher primate.com hire-primate.com.
That's my tee shirt company.
People keep asking me about it and I never promoted,
but some,
uh,
cool shit.
A lot of monkeys and mushrooms and a lot of stuff.
Very juvenile.
But that's me.
I'm very juvenile.
Yeah.
I'm in the monkey's in space ships and shit.
Who is that?
That's where there's a lot of monkeys as astronauts to it somehow.
That's a good idea,
dude.
I like what you thinking serious.
Should have monkeys with big tits.
Yes.
Huge big nipples.
Okay.
That's the next one.
All right folks.
We will,
that's,
we're done with this week.
Uh,
but we will see you soon.
I will also be on Duncan trussell's new podcasts.
It's the Duncan Trussell family hour.
I'm actually heading there right now.
Is that crazy or not?
Jesus fucking Christ.
All right.
Goodnight.
Everybody will love you.
Thanks.
Bye.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
okay.